it being two o'clock
I will call this
finance committee hearing to order
this is the public hearing for hb1 and
hb2
spreadsheets for all the agencies in
government
and we go through that page by Page and
split it up amongst the divisions of the
finance committee we also have hb2 which
is another 200 pages that has that is
called enabling legislation because
since the
hb1 is spreadsheets if there are
numerous changes to reorganize things if
the taxes increase decreased or changed
that would have to be an hb2 if there's
a reorganization of some Department
which affects their budget that would be
an hb2
there already has been a very voluminous
reorganization of the office of
professional licensure licensing and
certification we have received that and
passed it over to another committee on
in the house that's called executive
departments and administration they deal
with these licensing and all that sort
of thing they have already had a lot of
input and I'm sure some of you will as
well and I'm waiting to find out I don't
think they're going to cancel all the
licenses that are mentioned in hb2 I've
asked someone to get me a report on what
licenses have really been removed I
don't see that remember here but I
expect we might have it
during our time here there it is
not ready yet but he's finding it out
so
we're here to take your your
input to what the budget is before us
we've been working on it for a few weeks
and we have a couple more weeks to go
before we complete it we may decide to
change it if there's a lot of input from
all of you to things that are
distressing within the budget we will
try our best to accommodate everyone
however we started with a real a real
challenge
the gov we had a input from the governor
and we began with that then we wait for
another Committee in the house called
ways and means that does all the revenue
estimates they gave us a revenue
estimate a couple of weeks after we got
the
the budget from the governor and it was
85 million dollars less than the
governor supposed
so right away we had that challenge
we also have 52 bills that came through
this house chamber and were passed and
had a fiscal note on them then those
must come to the finance committee as
well so we're dealing with those bills
if possible we will retain the bill it's
specifically and try to incorporate it
in the budget if it spends a little
money
so those are the challenges we have
before us we have some very busy days
ahead
we're delighted here's my committee to
listen to all of you and and your
concerns with this budget we definitely
want it to be something that we will be
proud of and feel that we have done
something to advance New Hampshire as
the wonderful State we all believe it to
be
so
since there's a lot of you that may have
the same issue
if possible if someone else has already
spoken about a topic that you are also
concerned about
you can say I agree with a previous
speaker on such and such a topic I would
need not need I need not add anything
more or I would like to add one more
detail so you can take less time
we're going to Time Each speaker to
three minutes we always have a saying in
this house a three-minute speech is the
best speech because you can get your
points out there emphasize them get
enough of them in there I practiced it a
lot believe me and then be done so
three minutes will be timed for each
person that speaks you'll come to one of
those microphones make sure it's on
if you see a red light when you push the
button on the front then it should be
working
so
we also are accommodating people who
will use American Sign Language they're
seated over here
one of the early requests I had was
someone that has to get back to his job
and he wants to speak on hb1 so I will
recognize Frank Campbell
Mr chairman committee members my name is
Ray Campo and I'm a sergeant with the
state police and I also serve as the
president of the Troopers Association I
am thankful for the opportunity to speak
today and would like to express some
reasons why it is important to fund the
wage increase for the State Police in
this coming budget
in the last five years we have received
a total of a 5.32 wage increase that
number Falls far behind inflation and
even further behind many of the local
police departments we are not even in
the top 15 highest paid agencies in the
state
the Staffing crisis and the state police
is well known to put it in perspective
from 2015 through 2019 the state police
had 70 retirements and 12 resignations
in that five-year span that is
approximately 14 retirements per year
and approximately 0.41 resignations per
year
from the beginning of 2020 through the
end of 2022 retirements and resignations
have skyrocketed retirements are up 42
percent and resignations are up 175
percent
and it's worse the state police had a 20
vacancy rate
something changed however
we are almost into the second quarter of
2023 and the state police has seen only
one retirement notice and one
resignation notice
in addition we recently hired five new
Troopers
what caused this traumatic change
at the end of 2022 the treatment
Association of the state came through
technical agreement on a new contract
that a generous
ly
the reference of this wage increase the
Troopers Bill valued and it is important
for them to not retire and a few more
years will not seek out employment with
other police agencies in the state
I hope this perspective that I gave will
help all to understand the importance of
funding this wage increase and allowing
I will next call upon Holbert
and we're going to have someone doing
go up to the mic there and and we have a
foreign
proposal
um
the
licensure order issues about
interpreters are very different than any
device
so
so given the Vocational Rehabilitation
is understanding of people with
disabilities until I feel really
important the license
thank you
if there's anyone else that knows of
anyone that needs American Sign Language
I guess we
please come to see Laurie
foreign
feedback
and
um
good question would be the impact on the
representation of the board and we feel
it minimum the issue of Transportation
with
wood tables
thank you Lori hold your hand up if
anybody else knows of anyone else that
will need the American Sign Language
Laurie will be sitting down here in the
[Music]
all right all that
all right
all right I'll next call on Christy
stellato
welcome
thank you very much for having us here
all to bring with me
different opinions to your consideration
I'm Dr Deborah Warner I'm an electric
psychologist I am here
on representing the board of psychology
is
my name is attorney Elizabeth my
important Council to the board of
psychology
we will share this microphone for this
opportunity to share the board's
Louis Jim merger of the mental health
related boards proposed in sections
443-44
and 445
as introduced to accomplishment diverse
field covering more than 20 types of
practice
Awards five
the diversity
issue 2 is indicates this diversity and
it only allows just one psychologist one
schools
true and these decision making to a
majority of non-psychologists
adjudicate beyond their qualification to
the New Hampshire board of psychology
has been in existence for more than 60
years and
a team here when it was under the board
of mental health records the board was
restored in 2013 to rightfully follow
the practice
so that in Hampshire
could received
an emergency care for their
psychological needs
to me the board has been responsive to
adaptive license and will require
so licenses could be issued quickly by
the board
continuing education requirements has
in a communication with professional
thinner and without bias
school psychology
implementing Fair procedures for
licensing
consistency
and it shares
professionals
ified we expanded at the governor's
request that the board has brought
School psychologists into licensure at
the governor's request
communication
to regularly
regularly directly decorate its factors
the board members did this in record
time
is
did you give did you give the time for
both of them
no
there's two people speaking so we'll
[Music]
currently the board has five
psychologists one school psychologist
and three
polymers
in this competition award is able to
actively distribute work develop a
policy and identity applications and
discipline
the
proposal in ac2 section 445 has just one
psychologist or school psychologist on a
newly learned support of mental health
practice and only one public member on
that board and after they gave a higher
level
together on board and limited to just
one aspect from practice
all right we'll see if we'll see if you
have I have two cards for you I don't
know if I have a card for the second
person
all right
so all right uh Dr Warner I'm going to
if we have time
okay
we have another person that's going to
use the sign language interpreter
so we'll take that person up to the
microphone
Susan
suitable balance
former executive director Northeast
right away and so
there was not a lot of information
where you had a very good experience to
um
you actually can imagine
what the effort is to get his prefer to
thank you
all right I'm next going to call Joni
O'Brien and then after her Lara
Cooling
I can't read it Orford New Hampshire
Laura Cooley
at this point it's very short-sighted or
during
historical narcissist it um
it has several problems
the current board will be reenacted for
will have one emulator professional it
will not
input based on
putting and cleaning of the
award I have lines and areas written
really deeply at eliminating the alcohol
drug
Accord
[Music]
you can turn them in here at the front
table and all the members will get a
next we'll have Laura
cool leave
I'm sure she'll tell me how to pronounce
that provides for the executive director
to be able to set policy with the advice
of free
professionals two are licensed at the
many Professionals in
revivals are extreme
but I think that merging some of those
Sports would actually be a very good way
of making them collaborate and
understand each other's policies and
January filters coming from
really missing disciples for a long time
in this services to our citizens
I also work directly
with that for many years and I do agree
with their point of view that is very
s
of society is much higher
than anybody else
so
we could be doing a lot of food with
your acupuncture in this state if we
were set free and if people had freedom
to debate and provide the service that
the power to make them make those
decisions
and it is constitutional thank you so
much thank you
thank you next I'm going to call on
Frank knock
better
the first is on age 30 starting online
23.
[Music]
yeah I just want to point out a few
things
incarceration any character should look
like and I'm looking forward to a few
things that I think are really important
so if you look at
chronic statistics for example we have
our the critical population of recent
years
if you look at a current statute between
2014 and 2021 which is the most recent
Nation
at the same time you know around half
the people currently incarcerated in our
prison system right now are there for
parole violations and we think the
majority of those are for technical
violations so again most of those people
if we had more time since parole reform
would not be in the system and again we
would not need those people that space
available we also know that there are
significant number of people waiting in
our prisons because we have a lack of
community halfway houses and Community
Supervision and so but for the lack of
that we would again have a decrease in
our prison population so having this
conversation about setting aside 50
million dollars for construction without
looking at the long-term voter prison
system should or shouldn't look like we
think is troubling I also want to point
out some concerns we have on page 34.
starting on line seven which is with
regard to the quote northern border
Alliance program
and again this is setting aside about
1.4 million dollars to beef up policing
within 25 air miles of the Canadian
border
and I just want to give you some context
so when we had immigration checkpoints
for example up north
and this is not the ACLU speaking this
is a New Hampshire Court speaking
so while the court found in that case
around checkpoints because the
government was arguing that we needed
these checkpoints for immigration
enforcement the courts found quote that
while the stated purpose of the
checkpoints in this matter was screened
for immigration violations the primary
purpose of the action was detection and
seizure of drugs and so again I think we
have concerns that we're going to be
allocating all this revenue for
something that we know in fact is likely
going to be used to go after low-level
drug possession cases and so again one
point your time is expired thank you
thank you thank you
Drew Klein is next followed by Mark
McMurphy
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee I'm Drew Klein
president of the Josiah Bartlett Center
for Public Policy New Hampshire's free
market think tank we are here to speak
on the occupational licensing portion of
hb2
when considering the occupational
licensing reforms and the governor's
proposed budget the first thing to
understand is that the separate pieces
fit together
into a comprehensive reform package
each one seems to stand alone but they
work together to achieve maximum benefit
for New Hampshire residents and
consumers lawmakers should resist the
temptation to pick the package apart
transferring license licensing Authority
from the individual boards or the
Secretary of State's office to the oplc
is crucial to making the licensing
process more efficient and reducing
industry capture of the licensing
process granting automatic license
Reciprocity for licenses held in other
states improves efficiency reduces
regulatory capture and increases
competitive market forces that benefit
consumers
converting eight smaller boards to oplc
advisory boards improves efficiency
reduces regulatory capture and is a
better model for many boards than giving
the industry itself regulatory Authority
merging related boards also improve
sufficiency and reduces capture
and finally eliminating eight boards and
34 licenses is a huge pro-consumer
reform that eliminates needless
regulatory obstacles that limit
competition discourage professionals
from moving to New Hampshire
and impose unnecessary costs on numerous
Industries
these eliminations will not compromise
public health or safety
of the eliminated professional licenses
so that excludes the booths for Barbers
and the Peddlers Hawkers and itinerary
vendors just looking at the professional
licenses
all but one has a national
regulatory Authority a national
certification Authority or some other
National Industry test or exam
it's only The Apprentice soil scientist
that I could not find a national test a
regulatory body for and that's only
because the professionally soiled
scientist Society of America
doesn't have a separate Apprentice test
they have the test for everybody
so when you go down the list whether
you're looking at soil science Society
of America the cardiac credentialing
International the Society of American
Foresters the American Society of
Landscape Architects you just go down
the list there's a National Society or
um governing body that provides a
certification exam the one caveat to
that is athlete agent there's not like a
national athlete agent body but the
professional sports players
association's license or certify rather
and register their agents and insult na
the NCAA
is doing the same thing for basketball
players so
there's no your time is inspired about
um public health or safety compromise
thank you
thank you next we'll hear from Mark
thank you my name is Mark McMurphy I'm
the executive director of white birch
Center in Henniker New Hampshire we do
child care school age programming and
Senior programming and I'm here to
support the governor's budget hb1 for
child care
and having a lot of business background
prior to going into this position 10
years ago and no child care background I
can share what I've learned and that is
not only is child care critical to Child
Development critical to Working Families
but it's also critical to the economy
and that is the primary message that I
want to send today and I hope you
support it thank you thank you
Shannon Tremblay will is next followed
by
chairman and committee members I am here
in support of the governor's Department
of Health and Human Services budget as
it is proposed I'm here today wearing
two hats not only as a child care
provider but I also have a toddler and a
college age student we'll talk about
that later
but the
the problem is is that we'll I'll be
spending just as much on child care as a
college tuition and parents don't have
the accessibility or the affordability
of child care
um
and the budget will allow more families
better access and for affordability to
check Early Childhood thank you
thank you
hello my name is Amanda Sears I'm the
director of the campaign for a
family-friendly economy here in New
Hampshire
as the previous two speakers I am also
here in support of child care funding
for Working Families in the budget
you'll find that on starting on page 890
in the budget
um we do need to support the funding
that is in there this is really
important for Working Families it allows
them to be able to have assistance to
pay for their child care bills and be
able to get out and join our Workforce
and participate in our Workforce since
the pandemic we have had a 10 decrease
in women in the New Hampshire Workforce
and this is largely a result of the lack
of access to child care I did a forum
recently I participated before in one
child care center in Manchester and they
had two classrooms that were empty
because they don't have enough staff to
fill there to fill their Center so every
week they have 25 slots they can't fill
because of these empty classrooms and
when you multiply that across the state
that's a lot more spaces so in addition
to child care support for Working
Families I would implore the committee
to add into the budget funding for
Workforce supports for the child care
sector because we not only need some
distance for families we need more spots
in this state one place you can look for
a good model policy on how to do that to
add into hb2 would be Senate Bill 237 so
I would encourage you to take a look at
that and increase not just support for
working families and scholarships for
assistance but also supports for our
Workforce our child care Workforce
because it's the workforce that supports
the whole rest of our Workforce thank
you
thank you next we'll call on Alyssa
margolian
followed by
Laura Milliken
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Alyssa Markle and I service director of
housing action New Hampshire where
Statewide Coalition of 80 organizations
and businesses United around affordable
housing policy and ending homelessness
in New Hampshire I'd like to talk to you
about key housing and homeless Services
related proposals in hb1 and hb2 as you
know we have a severe housing crisis in
the state it's estimated that to meet
current needs were 23 000 units behind
to meet future needs over the next 30
Years where 60 000 units behind we have
record low Supply and we appreciate that
the governor's proposal handed over to
the house includes many Key Programs
that I'd like to bring to your attention
the governor in hb1 has highlighted the
affordable housing fund this is one of
the most important resources for
affordable housing development in our
state providing below market rate
Capital to developers so they'll build
more affordably and requiring
affordability periods that benefit the
residents the second one is the invest
New Hampshire program a new program that
was created with arpa dollars
administered by the Department of
Business and economic Affairs also has a
lot of promise and we should sustain
those funding proposals that the
governor has proposed with surplus funds
in hb1
in addition the governor proposes a new
housing tax credit for historic
affordable housing this is a great idea
to convert our aged historic
infrastructure into some useful
affordable homes for New Hampshire
residents finally I want to bring to
your attention homeless Services
as you know we have a homeless crisis
and we have
um the HP one is flat funded on homeless
Services we urge you to include the
prioritized needs requests from DHHS
that would be 20 million dollars to buy
more beds through homeless service
contracts and four million dollars for
eviction prevention thank you I'm happy
to take any questions I am thank you
Laura Milliken is next followed by
Pamela keilig excuse me you had
mentioned Kim ventola earlier and I
I overlooked and that's okay may I go
say that again please I'm Kim ventola I
haven't had a chance
this is for the Safford group no
I heard you call my name
what did I've got a person up next and
is this Lara
thank you
terminal
hey my name is Laura Milliken I'm the
executive director of New Hampshire
hunger Solutions a Statewide advocacy
non-profit seeking to end Hunger New
Hampshire
Medicaid direct certification
automatically enrolls children already
receiving Medicaid and whose family
income qualifies them for free and
reduced meals without families needing
to submit a separate application
it reduces child food insecurity and
reduces administrative burden on school
districts we all want to be responsible
managers of our public resources and
ensure that government is working
efficiently and is helping not harming
New Hampshire communities Medicaid
direct certification will make access to
a federal nutrition program more
seamless for those eligible
and and for the schools that implement
it it has the potential to ensure that
six to seven thousand more children have
the nutrition support they need to do
well in school and it ensures our
schools are getting every penny they
deserve for serving New Hampshire's
children
School meals improve health outcomes in
the short and long term and improves
child behavior and academic outcomes
Medicaid direct certification is more
accurate is a more accurate way to
measure children within schools who are
living with low incomes
during the pandemic when USDA waivers
allow for all children to eat School
meals for free for free families did not
have the ability to apply for meals that
was for three years or did I'm sorry did
not did not apply for meals they did not
have to those waivers ended in October
but we believe there are still many
families who don't know that forms are
needed and as a result the free and
reduced meal counts are down
substantially in most districts and
Medicaid direct certification would help
with that collecting forms is incredibly
burdensome for schools and for many
families who fall through the cracks it
misses them uh the Department of Health
and Human Service and Department of
Education have had an agreement for 16
years to share direct certification data
so that children on snap and TANF those
homeless migrant and Foster Care are
enrolled in Head Start can be directly
certified for free and reduced meals
there's never been a privacy issue in
fact Medicaid direct certification is a
much more secure way to convey data than
having children or families deliver
forms to school Medicaid direct
certification is a benefit to students
and a benefit to schools it's a win-win
for New Hampshire we know how to do this
right in New Hampshire because we value
efficient government and take seriously
our responsibility to ensure that the
Next Generation has every opportunity
for help
please support Medicaid direct
certification in the budget and I've
submitted written testimony thanks so
much thank you
call on Aaron Justina followed by Holly
Stevens
everything
New Hampshire legal assistance
sorry excuse me Mr chair you called my
no thank you so much and I promise to be
quick
um good afternoon Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Pamela kylig
and I'm the public policy specialist at
the New Hampshire Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence the
Coalition is the Statewide network of 12
independent community-based crisis
centers that provide free and
confidential services to victims of
Domestic and Sexual Violence and on
average Our member programs support
approximately 15 000 Granite Staters
every year we as a collective are in
support of the proposed general fund
appropriation for domestic violence
programs in hb1 and are extremely
grateful for the support that we've had
for this appropriation in the past this
allocation would ensure that the state
budget adequately funds efforts to
improve our response to Domestic and
Sexual Violence
across the state and ensure that
critical life-saving services are
available available to victims and their
children when they need them crisis
centers play an essential role in our
communities to support those who are
impacted by abuse and address the short
and long-term effects of trauma through
the funding crisis centers will be able
to provide core services including
emergency shelter the operation of our
24-hour crisis helplines and allow for
Advocates to accompany victims to court
proceedings and hospital visits
Advocates also refer victims to a
variety of different interventions
within the community depending on their
need including Mental Health Services
substance abuse treatment and housing
so just to kind of end when victims and
survivors find the courage to reach out
and ask for help it is critical that
crisis centers are able to respond with
with the services that they need and for
example in 2021 more than 82 000 calls
were made to our crisis hotlines
um so unfortunately the need is strong
still in our communities we urge you to
please pass the full proposed funding in
the budget and just continue to thank
you for your support for our crisis
centers thank you
thank you sorry for Mr Mis shuffling the
cards
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Aaron Jacina
and I direct the domestic violence
advocacy project at New Hampshire legal
assistance and HLA is a non-profit Law
Firm we help low-income people with
civil legal issues I am here today on
behalf of our domestic violence advocacy
project because the governor's budget
included an additional 750
000 per year for Legal Services related
to domestic violence
we represent low-income victims and
survivors of domestic violence sexual
assault and stalking in their highly
lethality protected order and family law
cases when I say high lethality I refer
to those cases where our client is at
significant risk of being seriously
harmed or killed by their partner even
focusing our resources on cases
involving high risk of lethality we have
to turn potential clients away every
week
we are turning away cases where one
parent has threatened murder suicide
against the other parent if the police
are called to assist
we are forced to say no to elderly and
disabled clients who have been strangled
on multiple occasions and have been
threatened with bullets to their head
we received
from help for help from victims who have
been sexually assaulted poisoned
abandoned in the most remote parts of
our state and psychologically terrorized
every day
we do not have enough staff to say yes
to all of these cases less than 15
percent of domestic violence victims
have legal representation
when they go to court to get protective
orders for stalking it's less than five
percent I am asking you today to please
allow us to say yes
the judicial branch domestic violence
task force was convened after a New
Hampshire woman was shot in the head by
her ex-partner as she was leaving work
after being denied a protective order
the task force issued a report in March
2022 it recommended additional funding
for civil Legal Services related to
domestic violence
the governor's budget included an
additional 750
000 per year to do exactly that
with this increased funding
nhla will be able to hire as many as
seven additional paralegals and
attorneys allowing us to handle we
project all of the cases that are
referred to us that involve domestic
violence with a high risk of lethality
to the victim thank you for your
consideration and your time today
thank you so I said Holly Stevens would
be next but I'm told I cut off Kim
ventola is Kim still here
all right after Holly you will speak I'm
sorry about misreading something too
many cards here Holly Stevens followed
chairman well are members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify today my name is Holly
Stevens and I'm the director of public
policy for Nami New Hampshire the
National Alliance on Mental Illness at
this time Nami New Hampshire is not
taking a position on either House Bill
one or House Bill 2. however we do have
some concerns that we would like to
express related to sections
282-284. we are in the middle of a
mental health crisis with one of the
most visible symptoms being emergency
room boarding a lack of both inpatient
and community-based resources has
primarily led to this crisis
while there have been significant
Investments and much accomplished in the
implementation of New Hampshire's
10-year mental health program excuse me
10-year mental health plan we know that
it is vital to expand and enhance that
work to address the needs of all Granite
Staters affected by mental illness and
suicide
as reference sections
282-284 was significantly impact when
its data's requiring involuntary
admission to a psychiatric unit
while Nami New Hampshire applauds the
intent of this provision to create
additional drf capacity we do have
significant concerns
the creation of new drf beds should be
done with careful consideration of
multiple factors including quality of
care Workforce and the location of
existing services
Granite theaters requiring inpatient
level of care need treatment that is of
the highest quality and is both
evidence-based and trauma-informed it is
unclear if a two-bed drf unit could
consistently deliver this quality of
care
New Hampshire is currently experiencing
a mental health Workforce shortage to
the point that New Hampshire hospital
has two units that are closed due to
lack of Staffing and at this time the
furthest North in the state that there
are any drf feds is Franklin which is
Merrimack County
considering most of New Hampshire's
largest hospitals are on the Southern
Tier of the state as drafted House Bill
2 would likely perpetuate this unequal
access to inpatient psychiatric
resources felt by the North country
if these factors are not considered it
will result in an ineffective fragmented
approach rather than the successful
comprehensive system of care that
Granite stators need and deserve
additionally this bill contains a
provision that would amend the language
in RSA 135 c28 which currently requires
that person shall be immediately
transferred to a drf once the paperwork
for the iea is completed House Bill 2
removes the word immediately
which would result in further delay in
life-saving treatment for individuals
experiencing Mental Health crisis
it would make it legal for them to be
boarded indefinitely in an emergency
room receiving little to no treatment
therefore Nami New Hampshire opposes the
removal of the word immediately from the
current statute
thank you for your time and attention to
this matter
thank you Kim ventola is next followed
by Kristen Evans
thank you so much
I bring a lot of heart today and I'd
love to share photos of my son that's
okay
okay so good afternoon my name is Kim
ventola I live in Hopkinton New
Hampshire I moved here from Phoenix
Arizona in 2017 with my family I'm
asking you to support the developmental
Services budget and the proposed
Medicaid rate increase this proposed
Medicaid rate increase will support the
developmental disability system in
Workforce
there's currently a Workforce crisis in
New Hampshire for developmental services
to attract and retain qualified workers
my family member is supported by
Community Bridges through the in-home
supports waiver
I want to tell you a little bit about my
son my five-year-old Manny he loves
swimming horseback riding gymnastics and
Santa Claus acting building forts making
music and learning about cars Manny was
also Born Into the foster care system
with bilateral microphobia which means
he's completely blind with no light
perception and wears prosthetic eyes
my husband and I were lucky to meet this
funny musical energetic imaginative and
curious child when he was just eight
months old
while he still has a loving relationship
with his biological mother we were
fortunate enough to adopt him two years
ago
we have learned over the past past five
years how vital access to support
services is for Manny and our family
we are profoundly appreciative of
opportunities he has access to and in
the in-home support we receive as we
could never do this alone
as Manny ages his needs increase
he must continue to learn how to
navigate the world without sight develop
Independence and thrive in a world that
is not designed to accommodate him
easily
in addition he has a sleep disorder as a
result of his lack of light perception
imagine how confusing it is for him to
not know when the Sun rises or sets each
day
also please imagine how exhausting it is
for Mom and Dad to only get a few hours
of sleep over a few days
the exhaustion has a ripple effect on
our professional lives as well as our
teenage son
loving Manny comes very easily
on the other hand
comes with many challenges
finding staff has been our greatest
challenge so far
my husband and I desperately need more
in-house home support to keep Manny safe
on the path to Independence
and to get a good night's sleep
thank you chairperson Wilder and the
members of the house finance committee
for considering testimony I urge you to
support a Medicaid rate increase for
developmental Services thank you
thank you Kristen Evans is next
and then
come on ahead and I'll ask
representative McGuire to make an
representative McGuire has information
about how many let's hear his
announcement
ready enough
yes
okay so there's a very large section of
House Bill 2 that makes a lot of changes
to professional licensing and so we
handed all that to the executive
departments and administration committee
which deals with professional licensing
bills and they went over this and and
are making significant suggestions for
changes to first of all eliminations
changes to the law the language of House
Bill 2 and they also have some of their
own bills that they can change in in
related ways
so in particular for those licenses
being eliminated in the house bill
2. there are
seven that they are recommending that we
do not eliminate and those are
Apprentice soil scientists Apprentice
Wetland scientist Forrester landscape
architect soil scientist and Wetland
scientist and also the LNA
section they're recommending that they
keep that in their own committee to
possibly work on in a related bill so
those seven will will likely not be part
of house bill 2. we're going to get on
Friday at one o'clock in in our
committee room a more detailed
explanation for their suggestions and
amendments to House Bill 2. thank you Mr
chairman
thank you go ahead Kristin you that your
honorable chair and members of the New
Hampshire house finance committee my
name is Kristen Evans and I'm the
director of policy at able New Hampshire
able fights for the civil and human
rights of children and adults with
disabilities I do have written testimony
to submit that goes into more detail but
I will keep my testimony short for the
sake of time as New Hampshire's only
disability Justice organization we
strongly support funding the increase of
the new house New Hampshire house bills
one and two these bills provide critical
funding to support individuals with
disabilities and their families
including funding for Medicare
reimbursement rates and an increase in
funding for the Medicare waiver system
however we also urged the committee to
consider additional increases Beyond
those proposed in the legislation
individuals with disabilities have been
overlooked and underfunded resulting in
systematic barriers to their full
participation in society please support
funding HB one and two for people with
Developmental and other disabilities
served on the DD ABD IHS and CFA
Medicaid waivers to live inclusive and
productive lives in the community and
the Medicaid rate increase to support
the workforce needed to deliver these
Services by investing in these critical
Services we not only support individuals
with disabilities in living full and
independent lives but we also contribute
to the overall well-being being and
prosperity to our communities we urge
the committee to consider the long-term
benefits of investing in disability
services and to prioritize the needs of
individuals with disabilities in the
state budget thank you for your
consideration and commitment to ensuring
a more Equitable and just Society for
all
thank you Kristen we'll next call on
Jennifer Bertrand followed by Susan
Stearns
thank you for your patience a little
trouble getting in on my bag my name is
Jennifer Bertrand
um I live in Mount Vernon New Hampshire
with my family and I'm a devoted parent
I am the mother of a daughter an adult
daughter who experiences a developmental
disability
um her name is Chloe she's going to
testify in a few minutes here too she
has a variety of medical complexities
and I'm here to ask you to please
support funding for services for Home
and community-based Services people that
have served on the DD waiver ABD waiver
CFI CFI Weyburn so forth and also to
support a Medicaid rate increase she's
an energetic 23 year old she lives in
very meaningful and active life right
now in the community
she works as much as she can to be
productive she has a little business
Chloe Shred Shed and the pandemic has
made things really difficult
just can't find workers and the few work
workers that we do have we live in
constant fear that we could lose them
because the wages that these workers
earn are very very low and they have an
incredible amount of responsibility
Chloe also has a significant seizure
disorder we need people who are capable
to support her and keep her safe and
help her live a productive life
so I ask you to please support funding
for developmental services and funding
for the Medicaid waivers and a rate
increases a little picture of Chloe and
my husband and I that's inside of hers
Red Shed where she works thank you for
your consideration
thank you
good afternoon chairman Weiler members
of the committee for the record my name
is Susan Stearns and I'm a resident of
samberton in the interest of full
disclosure I am employed as the
executive director of Nami New Hampshire
however I am not representing Nami New
Hampshire here today but myself as a
family member with two loved ones living
with serious mental illness
I'm here to ask that you ensure that the
budget you pass fully funds critically
needed Mental Health Services that are
accessible to all Granite Staters
my first loved one who is nearly 53
years old is a patient at Lakes Region
Mental Health Center and receives
Compassionate Care from their assertive
Community treatment team also called
acting
he has been an act patient since its
Inception in Laconia in July of 2013.
prior to that he spent his entire adult
life with repeated psychiatric
hospitalizations once for nearly a year
in the spring of 2013 after two
back-to-back instances of dangerous
self-harm that resulted in multiple
surgeries and a stay at the burn unit at
Mass General Hospital we thought he
would have to move into a facility with
24 7 supervision which he absolutely did
not want
just as we reached that critical
decision point the state budget went
into effect and included in that budget
was funding for ACT teams to be
Statewide including Laconia they began
visiting him daily a sitting with daily
activities of daily living and helping
him stay healthy and not having a
psychiatric hospitalization since
my second loved one is now my now adult
child who was first diagnosed with an
emotional disorder at age five a serious
one by age eight and a serious mental
illness by the age of 14.
it was a difficult Journey but we were
lucky
my employer offered health insurance
that covered my child and he was able to
access the mental health treatment that
kept him at home in school and not in
emergency department or residential
placement
as my child grew up there were many
sobering legalizations for me as his
mother that his path would likely be
different from that of other children
and that indeed he may not always be
able to work 40 hours a week all of us
is adult life
that he might not one day be able to
access treatment
that last one terrified me
my child had been a treatment success
story
despite some difficult times he never
required a visit to the emergency
department or a hospitalization
as my child approached his 26th birthday
he and I sat down to apply for Medicaid
expansion coverage for him a few weeks
later that letter erotic saying he was
covered and I wept
since becoming eligible for Medicaid
expansion my child has had periods when
he was been able to work and has his
health insurance and provided by his
employer or purchased it himself on the
marketplace
when times have been harder he has been
able to access the mental health
treatment necessary for him to live a
full life your time is expired
thank you I urge you to fully fund
fully fund mental health treatment so
that people like my loved ones can
access the care they need I do have
written testimony
thank you
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm Bob Dunn the director of
public policy for the Roman Catholic
Diocese of Manchester and I'm here today
on behalf of Bishop Peter obashi to
speak on House Bill one
um
and thank you by the way for all the
work that you have put into the budget
and that you're putting in today
just a couple of brief comments first of
all as a general matter
I urge you to please give a preeminent
priority in your decision making to the
poor and to those who are most in need
many of you have heard me say in other
contexts here this session that the
common good in human dignity are not
just religious principles but they're
principles that are at the heart of the
Constitutional order that was left us by
the framers starting with Article 1
Section one of the new part one article
one of the New Hampshire Constitution
which says that government has
instituted for the general good
I will um just speak to one aspect of
the budget in the interest of time and
that is the long-term care side of the
budget
almost by definition the people that
qualify for Medicaid nursing home care
are among the sickest and the neediest
of all of the citizens of New Hampshire
and so they are also greatly at the
mercy of what Pope Francis likes to call
the throwaway culture which disposes of
things and people that no longer have
um and so as a result I would uh urge
you to fund adequately the entire
long-term care system and in particular
uh to adopt the 15 increase on nursing
home funding that was proposed by the
New Hampshire Health Care Association in
front of division three
thank you thank you
Thomas Blonsky next followed by Sandra
Pelletier
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Tom Blonsky I
am the CEO of Catholic Charities New
Hampshire
we have six facilities representing 390
beds and there are fully 50 beds that
are vacant because of acute staff and
short agents that we have
so our current scenario is that we
experience a loss of 75 per Medicaid
resident per day and our Medicaid census
in our various facilities range from
anywhere from 50 percent to 70 as high
as 75 up in our facility in Berlin
our current scenario with our agency
budget pre-covered was just under three
million dollars post covet in this
year's fiscal year budgets is 10 million
dollars
this year in our fiscal budget we are
projecting 1.4 million dollar loss which
as you can imagine isn't sustainable
so historically Through The Years
Catholic Charities has cared for several
State officials reps and Senators
including Federal Senators family
members who came to us because of our
reputation for quality care we have
three five-star facilities and one four
star facilities two three-star
facilities
and we're not interested in selling out
to the many one and two star
out-of-state operators who bought up our
mom and pop nursing facilities or
smaller chains in the last couple of
years we don't want to get to the point
at that place financially where we have
no other choice but to sell because of
inadequate Medicaid funding
Never Say Never
if you were to need a nursing home bed
for yourself or a family member today
tomorrow or in the near future would you
want a facility that provides five-star
care or one star care
our seniors
who have gotten each of us to where we
are in part today deserve better quality
and the highest level of care in this
budget you have the ability to change
that and to sustain that for the future
I urge you to increase the Medicaid rate
for our state's nursing facilities by 15
in the new budget to save our nursing
homes and to save our seniors thank you
thank you Sandra Pelletier next followed
thank you for this opportunity this
afternoon my name is Sandra Pelletier
I'm a long-standing CEO of gateway's
community services in Greater National
one of the 10-year agencies that serves
individuals with developmental
disabilities children and adults
gateways also serves Statewide elders
and Veterans and I'm here to speak about
House Bill one and two in support of it
as well as Medicaid rate increase
the workforce crisis on top of the
pandemic has resulted in a perfect storm
due to Stepping shortages there's severe
lack of services programming treatment
and transportation for individuals that
we support daily
I can give you many examples in the last
three years have been pretty traumatic
for many of us who work in this field
with staff covering unfulfilled
positions every day the scope of the
work of our staff our service
coordinators particularly our direct
support Workforce cannot be told there
is many many stories to share with you
and some of our families are here today
to personally share what this challenge
has been for them personally the burden
is truly falling on family members and
we see extensive level of crisis with
limited ability to respond I'll give you
some examples of unfulfilled efforts on
our behalf and the scope of work that we
provide Gateway serves close through 3
000 individuals and close to 2 000
individual children and adults with
developmental disabilities 500 veterans
and 500 Elders please step back for a
moment as policy makers and realize this
could be your son your daughter your
grandchild your parent your grandparents
all need of these important services
over the last year I've watched our day
Services drop to 75 percent of their
capacity I've watched many of
individuals who need supported
employment who have been pretty excited
about the opportunity to work in their
adult lives lose their jobs because
there's no Transportation we'll tell you
last month in my board meeting during
the board meeting I started getting
calls because one of the national
Transportation Systems started to close
some of the service lines over the last
few months I had 20 individuals who had
long time employment opportunities
working at Dartmouth Hitchcock and other
centers who had no transportation in the
coming weeks fortunately a team of
people created some crisis response and
we were able to respond
I can go on and on and on our group
homes are working overtime at the
extensive level of overtime payment in
order to keep our 24 7 24 7 Staffing our
birth to three-year-old children are
being impacted daily Etc because of our
inability to hire occupational
therapists and physical therapists so
delayed services and evaluations are
occurring on the Elder side I've never
seen so many crisis I think some other
people have spoken to you about that
Elders in need of long-term care are
waiting to get into nursing homes we've
had many crisis we've watched
individuals have to stay long standing
in the hospital settings
my biggest fear behind before you today
is that you'll keep hearing about the
wealth the workforce crisis you're
hearing it across the country you're
hearing it here in New Hampshire across
our Human Service and Healthcare Fields
your time has expired sensitivity moving
forward we really need your your support
to overcome the
conventing time thank you for your
Art thank you
Carol Conforti Adams followed by Kelly
ludke
we're good
right there hello my name is Carol
Capote Adams and I'm here to ask you to
support part of the bill with Medicaid
waiver programs
okay
um I'm an individual living
independently with quadriplegia for 21
years
for 10 years I worked and spent all my
financial resources in 2022 I needed to
go on Medicaid I was glad there was
Medicaid for employed adults with
disabilities
this this me program allowed me to
continue to work because Medicaid is the
only insurance that will pay for
personal care attendance
under the Community Services
um
and this allowed me the personal care I
needed to continue to live independently
and to get in and out of my wheelchair
during this time and still now I work
with high school students to get as they
try to get their high school diploma I
work with newly injured spinal foot
injuries and other people with
disabilities encouraging them to get
their geds or take college classes apply
for employment and help them with health
and wellness activities
in addition I'm also a part-time Human
Service Department director for a child
welfare department at 65 I was told that
I needed to retire to get off disability
and get on retirement
and I was grateful that New Hampshire
passed mode Medicaid for older adults
with disabilities so I continue to live
at home and have personal care so I
could get up and still work as you know
a lot of older people have to continue
to work to support themselves
I'm asking you to support the increase
in medical care Medicaid services to
close the lodge funding gap of
individuals with disabilities and older
adults so they could choose to live
independently
I'm asking you to enhance the funds that
will ensure rates across Medicaid waiver
programs these are programs as I just
exploded that are needed so people don't
have to go to nursing homes and increase
the cost of taking care of us
and we could live independently so
please
support the increase in funding for that
and this budget funding is necessary to
keep people in our communities to be
productive contributing individuals
it to society even though I'm
quadriplegic and in the I and depended
on Personal Care day and night I still
contribute to our community and I am
joyful and have a purposeful life every
day and I need these services to
continue myself your time is expired
thank you very much
Kelly ludke
followed by Molly
gendro
good afternoon my name is Kelly lutke
I'm the chairperson for the Alcohol and
Other Drug use professionals board I am
testifying on behalf of the entire board
we would like to state that we do
appreciate the governor's efforts to
streamline the bureaucracy involved in
the licensing of New Hampshire
professionals and to reduce the
administrative challenges to oplc
we recognize that oplc has and continues
to work hard to make the process as
user-friendly as possible for those
seeking licensured health and Technical
professions to reduce barriers and
delays in the licensing process and to
better meet the needs of the New
Hampshire Workforce
we also recognize that oplc Staffing is
not sufficient at this time to carry out
all of its responsibilities in an
effective and efficient manner
we support the effort to reduce the
burden on the office charged with
overseeing managing and administratively
supporting all the work of the many
licensing boards and credentials in our
state
however we believe changes proposed in
hb2 will alter the fundamental structure
and decision-making process governing
the oversight of the health and
Technical professions and have
significant oversight
I'm sorry oversight
of the health and Technical professions
and significant unintended consequences
for licenses professions and the
citizens of New Hampshire
hb2 reduces the professional licensing
boards from The Entity with the
authority to ensure that ethical conduct
and integrity of its own profession to a
consultant role to a generalist office
that cannot have the expertise and broad
level of understanding of every
profession it supervises
removing boards from the role of
reviewing and approving applications for
licensing hb2's intention of Expediting
the application process for licensure in
actuality places additional
administrative burden on an already over
taxed oplc staff
fully Shifting the responsibility for
the investigation of ethical complaints
against licensees from the boards to the
enforcement unit of oplc would increase
the financial burden on oplc by
requiring the office to contract
externally for Content expert
consultation in the investigation and
enforcement of professional ethical
complaints rather than relying on the
volunteer expertise of recused board
members
the consolidation of the board of
Licensing for Alcohol and Other Drug use
professionals and the board of
psychology under the broader Board of
mental health practice further
complicates the work of an already
generalist professional board reduces
the number of profession-specific
individuals responsible for the
oversight of their respective
professions and increases the amount of
administrative support and
responsibility placed on oplc staff that
already struggles to meet the demands of
the boards they supervise and support
laidac board already administers four
credentials with individual scopes of
practice Preparatory requirements and
ethical time is expired thank you
thank you
Molly gendro
okay
hello and thank you for your time I'm
Molly gendro a licensed acupuncturist
and board member of the largest group of
acupuncturists in the state the New
Hampshire acupuncture in Asian medicine
Association I'm here on their behalf
we have been trying to wrap our brains
around this bill for the past two weeks
and we have very concerned of the
ramifications of the language and the
lack of information found in sections
289-301 in hb2
that would remove the board of
acupuncture licensing and replace it
for standard applications that check all
the boxes we believe the executive
director could do work effectively could
do that work effectively and efficiently
however our concern starts when an
application does not check the standard
qualifications
that are outlined by the law and the
executive director is tasked with
interpreting equivalency
hb2 minimizes that board that oversees
these decisions from two licensed
acupuncturists to two
sorry from four licensed acupunctures to
two
and removes the public member it adds a
detox specialist who is trained in only
one treatment a protocol on the ear this
bill is essentially cutting the
expertise of this board in half
the scope of practice for acupuncturists
is vast and the majority of our
practitioners here in New Hampshire are
self-employed the licensing board has
been critical in overseeing that our
public is safe in the hands of every
acupuncturist licensed thus far
their effectiveness is shown in the very
few disciplinary concerns brought before
the board
when balancing safety and efficiency
safety must take precedence
reducing the board's Collective
knowledge when interpreting equivalency
for medical education professional
training and understanding the scope of
practice is reckless
it is not enough for two people to
represent the entirety of this medical
profession
going from four people to two gives each
person immense influence there is
nothing in this bill that outlines the
process of who is chosen and how are
they vetted
although we would hope that any licensed
acupuncturist would uphold standards of
the profession to ensure Public Safety
we want to make sure that the board is
representing the voice of acupuncturists
in the state and not individual opinions
the New Hampshire a New Hampshire
acupuncture and Asian medicine
Association cannot stand behind this
bill as is there is simply not enough
time for the necessary critical
discussion to understand the logistics
and the future effects of these changes
to ensure the optimal outcome for health
and safety for all
we ask that sections
289-301 of hb2 be stricken thank you
thank you Ben Safford is next followed
by
chairman Weiler and house finance
committee members thank you for your
time I don't envy your job my name is
Ben Safford I live in Pelham my brother
and I have duchenne muscular dystrophy a
fatal muscle wasting disease with no
cure
we are here to ask you to support
funding in HP one and two for adults
with disabilities and the elderly on the
choices for Independence waiver my
brother and I live at home due to the
support of our widowed mother in The
Home Care Services we receive through
Medicaid
however due to increasing inflation and
the workforce shortage my mom has had to
take more of the time of caring for us
and and at her age now where she's uh
for a knee replacement and has some
issues with her diaphragm
um she's not able to really do the
caregiving that she used to do so
because of inflation she's had to do
more under the CFI waiver our caregivers
are only paid 14 an hour we no benefits
to care for not one but two of us
why would anyone want to stay in a
difficult Health Care job like ours when
they could make more money at Walmart
Market Basket or Wendy's our disease is
Progressive and as our health
deteriorates and my mom ages we will
need increasing levels of care to live
safely in our community
I implore you to keep the appropriation
to increase the Medicaid reimbursement
rate and to even further increase it to
bring some modicum of solution to our
current crisis
thank you for taking on the difficult
job of carefully examining and approving
the state's budget thank you
thank you Lori Safford is next followed
thank you
house finance committee members good
afternoon
my name is Lori Safford and I have two
adult sons on the CFI waiver Ben and Sam
need 24 7 nursing home level of care
I have sacrificed my career my time my
energy dreams finances my social life
and my own health
to keep them at home for the past 25
years
I am 60 and unable to physically care
for them on my own
it has been difficult if not impossible
to find home health care workers
a CFI Medicaid provider recently told me
that I'd have a better shot at winning
the lottery
than finding a new caregiver right now
I have been postponing surgery for a
paralyzed diaphragm in knee replacement
for over a year
but it can be postponed no longer
I meet with the surgeon next month
what would you suggest I do
Ben and Sam can't be left alone
[Music]
the CFI provider network is in danger of
collapse
these workers have not been giving given
a meaningful raise in over to 15 years
how much is the cost of food gas
electricity and home heating fuel
increased in 15 years
how can we possibly expect people to
work for fourteen dollars an hour with
no benefits in 2023.
a three percent or even a six percent
increase in wages is a drop in the
bucket especially with the availability
of easier higher paying jobs
is serving up burgers and fries or
stocking store shelves more important
than toileting dressing feeding and
caring for human beings made in the
image and likeness of God
the state is cutting off its nose
despite its face if it doesn't provide
the services necessary to keep our
adults with disabilities and our growing
elderly population in their homes and
out of the hospitals nursing homes and
other institutions where there are no
beds or caregivers
I understand the plan is to put tens of
millions of dollars into the New
Hampshire rainy day fund
considering our home health care system
is in the midst of a violent tornado
this makes no sense to me
I urge you to do whatever it takes to
allow us to hire and retain retain
qualified home health care workers thank
you for your time
service and attention
thank you
Sam Safford is next followed by
okay
honorable house finance committee
members my name is Samuel Safford my
brother and I have duchenne muscular
dystrophy we're here to ask you to
support funding in HB 1 and 2 for adults
with disabilities and the elderly on the
choices for Independence waiver
my brother and I do not want to live in
it would be devastating for my brother
and I and more expensive for the State
of New Hampshire
however my mom is unable to physically
care for us by herself and she is
running out of my father's life
insurance money to pay for caregivers on
their own
without my mom providing Free Housing
clothing food transportation and Care
Ben and I would not be able to live
productive lives
we wouldn't be able to volunteer at our
church participate in our community and
Ben would not be able to retain his
part-time job working for a non-profit
that supports individuals with the
developmental disabilities
we can't find caregivers to work for 14
per hour with no benefits
please support a Medicaid rate increase
to help attract and retain qualified
home health care workers
our caregivers are taking care of people
who have inherent value and dignity
we are more important than the
environment or the rainy day funding
please support increased Medicaid
reimbursement rates to keep our elderly
and adults with disabilities in our
homes thank you
thank you
[Music]
I live at 50 South Main Street in Mount
Vernon
full funding for developmental services
and an increase of New Hampshire's
this will support people like me to live
board workers provide meaningful and
important care so we can focus on giving
back and better rates will help keep
these workers employed and interested in
[Music]
all right so
Jerry Weiler and members of the house
finance committee I'm ready today also
to support to ask for your support full
funding of Home and community-based
Services and hp1 hp2 as well as support
to the increase in New Hampshire there's
Medicaid reimbursement rates my wife
Jennifer and I lived in Melbourne for 22
years I was born and raised here in New
Hampshire
funding for Home and community-based
Services provides supports for our
daughter Chloe so she can remain in her
community and with her family she
requires support for all of her aspects
of daily living and she's while she's
autistic and non-verbal she uses this
support to fully participate in our
community and Achieve meaningful things
like the operation of our small Data
Destruction business colise redshed
which is now in its third year
something we established during the
pandemic because we we just really
couldn't find any support for her and it
was one of her dreams was to start a
business so that's what we've done
so the
you know workers in the direct support
field are very hard to come by these
days and they provide really vital and
incredible supports
and there's there's vendor agencies that
do surprise provide these supports but
we've they find it very hard to find um
to find and keep and attract support
workers
because it's you know a lot of people
just think it's easier to go to a basic
refund position it gets that that can
pay the same or more
so higher Medicaid rates would provide
this incentive for sport workers to stay
in the field that they love
so again full funding for its support
for developmental services and Medicaid
rates higher Medicaid rates is something
we would help you support it's something
you know the uh this approach of Home
and community-based Services in New
Hampshire is
over 30 years now it's worked and it's a
far less constant New Hampshire
taxpayers
thank you for your for your support on
this um now we're going to go back and
do some more shrimping
um I'm having trouble reading this name
William doubt it might be from the land
surveyors board if please correct me if
good afternoon thank you my name is Bill
Doucette from the New Hampshire land
surveyors board
speaking in opposition to House Bill 2
relative to the merger of the land
severe's board and the Professional
Engineers board
although we work together with the
engineers routinely on the national
level
on the local level we have a board of
four surveyors and one public member
we need all those members in order to
conduct our work if we reduce that by
half
the workload would remain the same and
taking on the addition of the engineers
board our workload would increase
between four to six times what it is
today thank you
good afternoon chairman Weiler and
members of the house finance committee
thank you for your time and opportunity
to speak on behalf of the New Hampshire
chapter of the American Society of
Landscape Architects my name is Randy
Knowles I'm a landscape architect and I
am the current trustee for the New
Hampshire chapter
we applaud the executive Department's
and administration committee's
recommendation to retain licensure for
Landscape Architects however before
taking this opportunity to provide input
and feedback on the development of a
multi-disciplined licensing board
I want to address a previous statement
by the representative of the Bartlett
Center for Public Policy to clarify
there is no National governing body
providing regulatory or certification
Authority for the landscape architecture
profession
the American Society of Landscape
Architects is strictly a membership
professional association and does not
have any legal role in regulating the
profession regulation of the profession
is done through all state licensure in
our profession is not opposed to merging
and combining boards however if
regulated under a multi-disciplinary
board landscape architecture should be
regulated along with one of our more
Allied design professions architecture
or professional engineering
as landscape architectures regularly
work with these design professions it's
common to see Landscape Architects
regulated with them additionally these
technical design professions share the
foundation of Education experience and
examination as the basis for licensure
as well as excuse me incidental practice
overlap in fact three-fourths of the
states 38 in total jointly regulate
Architects and Landscape Architects
under one board the most recent state to
enact this joint structure was Idaho in
2022. it's also important to recognize
that currently no State Licensing boards
regulate landscape architecture with
natural scientists or Forester
lastly we recognize there is a national
Trend focusing on licensing efficiency
combining boards and restructuring
licensing departments when done
correctly a multi-disciplinary board can
be an efficient licensing entity
that is why it is common to regulate
professions with similar licensing
structures and commonalities in practice
therefore we highly encourage the
committee to regulate landscape
architecture with a related design
professions allowing for an efficient
multi-disciplinary board benefiting
licensees and the citizens of New
Hampshire while continuing to protect
the public and environments throughout
our state thank you
thank you
Bill chapansky followed by Kelly Maggio
also from the ASLA if you have any if
good afternoon
chairman and members of the committee
thank you for this opportunity to
comment on the proposed rate increase
for private duty nursing and licensed
nursing assistant
provided by Home Health agencies
contracted with the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
I'm bill sapanski vice president of
Governor relations for team select Home
Care
team select not only Services private
duty patients and one office in New
Hampshire and Salem
but in over 40 locations in 1000 States
I come here today to address a reason
for the need for the rate increase for
private duty nursing and licensed RC
assistance from medically fragile
children and adults in New Hampshire
we are in support of a 40 percent rate
increase for private duty nursing
and a 24 increase for lysine nursing
assistance which would take the rate
under a home health benefit from 2440 an
hour to 32 dollars in line with what
lnas are reverse and other Medicaid
programs
with one office in Salem we almost
service 88 clients receiving both
private duty and L A Services these
clients skill needs range from a feeding
tube to trichosomy IV care some are 24 7
ventilator dependent most of our clients
are born with this condition that caused
them to need medical care in our home
for the rest of their lives
the nursing shortage is not a new issue
since 1980 the year I was born
the average age of an RN has only
increased signaling that there's not
enough nurses are joining a profession
according to Health Resources and
services Administration
even on the population of this
population of private duty nursing makes
up one percent of Medicaid system census
typically the cost can be up to 40
percent of Medicaid spent
I want to want to repeat that one
percent of the population can cause up
to 40 percent of spend why is that
needless hospitalizations without the
nurses available these children wind up
in the hospital
I did some research and found that
your neighbor in Massachusetts
unfortunately is taking a lot of your
nurses
that means that 21 of the LPNs who live
in New Hampshire have Massachusetts
license and 31 percent of the RNs who
live in New Hampshire have Massachusetts
license they don't have those licenses
for no reason they're going there for
for a reason that's because of the pay
other states have increased their rates
Missouri by 40 last year Arizona by 10
percent Virginia by 65 percent
Mississippi by 20 percent
I ask that you please join these states
increasing rates so we can staff these
cases appropriately and for these
reasons I decided I strongly urge you to
support the rate increase for private
dating and RC and Licensing our senior
assistance thank you
thank you
so I guess I
said Kelly
Maggio was next I have
quite a number of cards from
a Landscape Architects
Daniel brusca Jeff Highlands
George pelletieri Catherine Weiss and
Mark condom condomatraki
do if there's
if all these people are going to have
similar comments
please
don't be repetitious if there's unless
there's nothing to something new to add
we're aware of the problem and I don't
think we're going to eliminate that
license thank you go ahead of course so
my name is Callie Maggio I am the uh the
New Hampshire chair of American society
of landscape architecture secretary
I have already submitted my testimony
online and on behalf of our chapter and
the representatives here today we would
not want to waste any of your time given
the recent turn of events and the
conversations that we've had earlier so
I'm here just to say thank you very much
we appreciate you recognizing our
landscape architecture profession and
hopefully retaining it as this bill
moves forward and I agree on on the
behalf of our our landscape architecture
uh Representatives here we all agree
with the testimony Randy Knowles
provided thank you thank you Kelly what
who was it Randy Knowles he spoke a
couple okay so I also have Catherine
Weiss
New Hampshire and I would like to show
that I support everything that Randy
Knowles said
um and I hope that you will join our
board with a board that is similar to
what we what we thank you thank you
good afternoon I'm George bellicherry
from Warner I've been the landscape
architect practicing in New Hampshire
for 47 years
and I concur with the comments the
former
speakers
thank you Jeff
Daniel brisca and Greg
rusnika
hello my name is Dan bresca I'm a
licensed landscape architect in the
state of New Hampshire and I would like
to concur with Randy Knowles statement
and
you guys maintain our licensure as bill
must work thank you
I'm a resident of Sutton New Hampshire
and I'm a professional Lansing architect
I'd like to take care of with the
previous speakers and defensive
licensure and representation for
Landscape Architects
a public health safety and welcome
thank you
appreciate your brevity I didn't realize
there was that much work for Landscape
Architects and another thing that
I was pleased to hear when they talked
about eliminating this licenses oh we
haven't had that any complaints about
Celia Oliver
followed by Jennifer Martel who I guess
and members the house finance committee
I'm Dr Celia Oliver I'm a psychologist
and I'm representing the New Hampshire
Psychological Association I'm standing
with me are my colleagues who are also
psychologists
um
in addition to our written and verbal
testimony we have attached 99 signatures
obtained in nine hours on a Sunday you
can imagine what a feat that was and
this is over and above the 13 signatures
of all 13 members of the board of
directors of New Hampshire Psychological
Association
our request is straightforward
please remove sections
443-444 and 445 from hb2 as the Ed and a
committee recommended on Friday
and
please maintain the current structure of
an independence licensing board
psychologist
you have written testimony not only from
an HPA
but also aspb we like lots of letters
and things the association of state and
provincial psychology boards that is the
association of all psychology regulatory
boards throughout the United States and
Canada you also have written testimonies
from a number of individual
psychologists these written testimonies
highlight the specific difficulties of
dissolving the current board of
psychology and merging it with the board
of mental health practice
over 10 years ago the New Hampshire
legislature approved the formation of
the board of psychology
separate separating it from the board of
mental health practice
after The Growing Pains of the first few
years this separate licensing board has
been working effectively for both
psychologists and the public
an HPA supports increasing
administrative efficiency and we are
actively working with the Ed and a
committee to continue to promote
effective and ethical improvements
regarding costs license fees essentially
cover the cost of operating board of
psychology
consequently any cost savings for
merging the boards is minimal and will
not outweigh the cost to Public Safety
is also not a matter of elitism or some
sort of turf war psychologists and other
Mental Health Providers are constantly
working together collaboratively in a
wide variety of settings
what does not work is when we attempt to
regulate each other's professional
practices they are just too different
that is why the independent board of
psychology was established over 10 years
ago
in fact in the United States only one
State Kansas has a Consolidated board
for regulating the practices of
psychology
there are many very good reasons for
this governmental structure of one
licensing board for psychologists
we have already demonstrated the
Consolidated licensing board does not
work in New Hampshire
what we currently have is working
we ask you to please help us keep this
current structure and allow us to keep
working with the Edna committee and the
oplc to promote improvements in the
administrative processes
thank you so very much thank you for all
getting up together ten years ago I was
Jennifer Martel I forgot to include you
with the rest of the Landscape
Architects
thank you chairman Weiler and committee
members my name is Jennifer Martel as
you've guessed I am a licensed landscape
architecture from New Hampshire from
Exeter New Hampshire I'm also the
president of the New Hampshire chapter
of the American Society for Landscape
Architects many of our members are here
today and I just want to say that we all
are in concurrence with Randy Knowles
testimony about combining our board with
an Allied professional board if
combination affords is what proceeds out
of this and we look forward to the next
committee meeting next Friday thank you
an actual call on Catherine Sweeney
good afternoon chairman Weiler and
committee members my name is Catherine
Sweeney I'm the president-elect for the
New Hampshire court reporters
Association and proud New Hampshire
license court reporter number 166. I'm
here to speak on the potential repeal of
Licensing for court reporters
excuse me
what is also known as stenographers
we're the individuals who write down
everything that is said in illegal
proceeding and put it into a written
transcript attorneys fight for the
rights and Liberties of their clients
the litigants in order to gather
evidence for trial and effectively try
their case they call on license court
reporters to accurately take down
testimony at depositions and most
importantly protect that testimony court
report is not only right on our funny
little machines to take down the words
of everyone in the room but we ensure
that personally identifiable information
of those who testify is protected and
remains confidential things like
addresses Social Security numbers
banking institutions and account numbers
are very often testified to a deposition
years and years of tax returns are at
our disposal as exhibits and don't even
get me started on what kind of
photographs we say we not only know
about someone's pii but we also know
private information too what medical
conditions someone has the doctors they
see and the medications they take how
much someone makes at their job and what
their mortgages who has a safe where it
is in their home and what's in it spoil
alert it's cash and gold what a wife and
her tennis instructor do with tennis
lessons that husband pays for spoil
alert it's not only tennis
how many tens of thousands of dollars a
husband spends at the local gentlemen's
club and the real names of sexy kittens
Banky Jane to whom those funds go to you
can't prevent this information being
exposed to court reporters but you can't
prevent it from being disclosed to
unauthorized unlicensed individuals by
maintaining our licensure and ethical
obligations
certifications earned from our National
Association only test our speed and
accuracy as well as grammar spelling and
basic knowledge of core procedures
licensing and certifications go hand in
hand the national court reporters
associate Association does not issue
licenses to court reporters they are
just the governing body that states rely
on to provide testing and basic
guidelines
it is up to the individual states to
require that certification as a Baseline
and then issue licenses per that State's
specific rules and regulations
the national court reporters Association
also has cope the code of professional
ethics which we must follow and includes
data encryption and cyber security
integrity and partiality and competence
is part of New Hampshire licensing we
agree to abide by this code of ethics
which ensures that sensitive information
is not improperly disclosed if licensing
of court reporters is taken away there
is going to be zero oversight of who
will be responsible for taking testimony
being impartial and making sure the
personal information of citizens remains
private if our licensing is taken away
court reporters may not choose to remain
members of the National Association let
their certifications lapse and then they
will not be have to have to be held to
any ethical standards whereas yet anyone
can call themselves a court reporter
enter a private legal proceeding slap a
digital your time is expired it said
recordings off to who knows who please
all right I have Michelle broadhurst and
Gary Harding looks like from the same
firm we both have five minutes please
keep it to three minutes thank you
good afternoon chairman members of the
house finance committee my name is
Michelle broadhurst I'm a partner of the
law firm of Bernard Merrill located in
Manchester New Hampshire we are the
largest workers compensation defense
firm in the state our representative
clients include New Hampshire employers
and insurance companies some of our
representative clients are the largest
manufacturers in the State Health Care
Facilities supermarkets retail
industry school districts
we are we're here today uh with regard
to line item 115 that section that would
amend RSA 281 colon a section 54 and
would abolish the second injury fund the
second injury fund was a fund that was
set up for New Hampshire employers and
their insurance carriers and what it
does is it is a fund that is assessed to
the insurance carriers and the employers
which they pay into each year with their
own money and then when they retain or
hire Injured Workers and those Injured
Workers suffer a second injury while in
their employee they can access that fund
and would get payment back for what
they've paid out in Indemnity benefits
as well as medical benefits why this
fund is so important is that not only
does it protect your New Hampshire
employers and encourage them it
encourages them to hire Injured Workers
or workers who have disabilities it also
protects the injured worker it's an
added layer of protection for them as
well as
giving them the comfortability to know
that well maybe I injured my rotator
cuff and tore my rotator cuff and now
I'm back to work I don't have to work I
don't have to worry because if I get
injured again I know that my employer is
going to get reimbursed out of the
second injury fund and again the
important thing to understand here is
that this fund is solely funded by the
employers and the insurance companies it
is their money and so there's really no
need for this fund to be abolished it is
encouraging lawyers
to
hire and maintain and retrain Injured
thank you Gary Harding followed by Joni
Bernard
okay thank you Gary Hartford from
Bernard Merrill and I'm opposing House
Bill 2 only to the extent that you're
trying to Sunset or eliminate the second
entry fund the second industry fund was
created to
um encourage employers to hire people
with disabilities
and that's what it's there for there's
no taxpayer money involved in the second
entry funds there's uh like uh Michelle
said it's
employers it's the
the insurance carriers money and what
happens when the employer gets
reimbursed from the fund is their
premiums will go down
so it helps businesses with lower
premiums so why get rid of a funds that
isn't broken
there's there's no need to eliminate
this I hear that the only reason why
this is being introduced is because of
cases
denials of second injury fund there's
been an increase in denials and that's
only because the Department of Labor's
Administration has changed over so the
second injury fund coordinator is new
they're denying a lot more claims now
but what I've seen and I've been doing
this for 20 years now what I've seen
this year the past two years there's
there's like between 15 and 20 claims
maybe for a cycle
ink that's it 15 to 20 claims that need
hearings so we average that out over a
year you're looking at one to two claims
per month so you're going to eliminate a
multi-million dollar fund because of one
to two claims being processed per month
it just doesn't make sense so
we we respectfully request that that's
uh that the funds just stay where it is
there's no need to eliminate the fund
Joni Menard or Tony Menard followed by
and I'm a registered nurse in the state
of New Hampshire I'm the vice chair of
the Board of Nursing I am accompanied by
the chair of the Board of Nursing
Samantha O'Neill so we're going to
consolidate Our Testimony we also have
other members of the Board of Nursing
with us we're going to be speaking in
opposition
to the request in hb2 to remove
licensure for our licensed nursing
assistants in the state of New Hampshire
foreign
thank you
good afternoon in addition to opposing
for the removing the licensing of our
licensed nursing assistants we also have
some concerns regarding the composition
of the members of the Board of Nursing
and reducing it from 11 to 5. so the
Board of Nursing oversees over 50 000
licensees 12 000 of them are licensed
nursing assistants and approximately 1
000 of them are medication nursing
assistants
the Board of Nursing has the following
concerns with hb2 if L A's were no
longer required to be licensed there
would be a decline in the quality of
patient care as well as a risk to
patient safety one of the requirements
to be a medication licensed nursing
assistant is to First be an l a
medication nursing assistants provide
essential services to our long-term care
facilities and without this designation
of long-term care facilities we need to
have higher level licensees providing
this task creating more of a burden for
these facilities
are required to have more classroom and
clinical hours of training than a
certified nursing assistants which
provides them with more experience in
preparation to provide quality and safe
patient care
lnas are required to obtain continuing
education courses to ensure that they
are up to date on their skills and their
best practices unlicensed nursing
assistants are not required to
participate in continuing education
which will negatively impact patient
care lnas are required to meet ethical
and clinical patient care standards
under the nurse Practice Act is defined
in the New Hampshire Board of Nursing
rules failure to uphold these standards
requires Board of Nursing reporting
review mitigation to protect the health
and safety of the public
the Board of Nursing receives many
complaints on a regular basis 39 percent
of all complaints before the Board of
Nursing concerns lnas
between February of 2021 and February of
2023 we emergently suspended nine lnas
due to concerns that they were opposed
an imminent threat to the danger at
health and safety of the public should
they keep their license during the
investigative process
to be licensed in the state of New
Hampshire all licensee need to
successfully complete FBI fingerprinting
and criminal background check these are
very critical checks and are vetted
through the oplc and the Board of
Nursing to ensure that those individuals
receiving license are safe to practice
in all settings data gathered from the
past two years reflects that 81 percent
of all LNA applications came before The
Board of Nursing due to criminal history
or activity
in addition if L A's were no longer
required to be licensed they would not
be able to participate in the New
Hampshire professionals health program
which is a resource for all licensees 17
lnas have been part of that program
since its Inception
lnas are subject to permanent band of
licensure for certain felonies such as
manslaughter aggravated robbery
kidnapping felonious assault
exploitation of children and there is no
mechanism to provide this with certified
nursing assistance
as it relates to the compensation of the
Board of Nursing
the board is currently made up of 11
individuals nine clinical and two public
members again we have over 50 000
licensees and the current board
structure allows for a greater amount of
cross-functional expertise and knowledge
to make more informed and educated
decisions as it relates to licensees we
have members of the board with Hospital
ambulatory VNA long-term care and Human
Resources experience these variations in
experience allow us to tap into the
subject matter expert in certain
situations to better understand the
Dynamics processes and best practice in
those areas which again allows the board
to make more informed educated and
timely decisions for those reasons we do
not support reducing the number of board
members from 11 to 5. thank you are you
Samantha O'Neill I am okay and were
there any other cards here that I should
have from other nursing people
no we all are under the same board thank
you thank you very much for coming
together
push the button so it gets red there you
oh my name is Jessica Keeler I'm the
president of ski New Hampshire
yes I'm excited about the snow tomorrow
but I am also here representing uh
travel and tourism organizations as well
as Chambers of Commerce from throughout
the state on their behalf I'm here to
express support for the Governor's
proposed marketing budget figure for
fiscal 2425. I also do have a letter
here signed from 26 organizations from
around the state that I will bring down
after I'm done speaking so uh but I also
just wanted to like touch on a couple
bullet points and I'll be quick uh
tourism is a one billion dollar a year
industry in New Hampshire that results
in 55 million dollars in rooms and meals
tax which represents just over 10
percent of the state's general fund this
also helps support many of the important
programs that we've been hearing about
today
I'll also note that the division of
Department of travel and tourism
division development has a
well-documented Roi of 16 for every one
dollar spent on promotion
a piece of this budget supports the
joint promotional program a matching
grant program that many chambers and
tourism-related organizations use
including ski New Hampshire and it's
very important to how we operate
especially within marketing and
promotion
the overall dollars that travel and
tourism spends whether on their own
marketing campaigns or through
The Joint promotional program are really
critical for the many areas of the state
that rely on tourism to support local
jobs Municipal budgets and more without
those funds we would be hard-pressed to
do the work that draws visitors here it
helps local communities
I thank you for your continued support
of the travel and tourism industry and
for a fully funding the state's
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is Ross
Connolly I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire uh we're neutral on hb2 as uh
as compiled but here to speak uh and uh
in full-hearted support of the
governor's proposal for uh licensing
reform uh and uh reducing those barriers
to employment so these are common sense
proposals in our mind it will streamline
regulations boards and eliminate
unnecessary licensure requirements and
the governor's proposal will also make
New Hampshire a beacon in the Northeast
by taking the step to universally
recognized out-of-state qualified
licensed workers licensing recognition
recognition would reduce barriers uh to
dozens of occupations between New
Hampshire and the rest of the country
ultimately making New Hampshire a leader
in removing Interstate licensing
barriers over 20 percent of New
Hampshire's sessions require a license
some form of occupational license to
work and many of these are low-income
entry-level jobs where individuals are
seeking a more prosperous life to move
up the economic level these industries
and employers are struggling to hire
more workers so simply recognizing the
investment that they've already made in
their home states to gain a license
in recognizing that work is a very
straightforward and easy way to boost
New Hampshire's economy and still
protect the health and safety of its
residents
the governor also proposed eliminating
or streamlining 34 licenses many of
these such as Hawkers and Peddlers and
itinerary embed vendors the elimination
of those that uh have passed this this
house uh many times in the past few
years with very little opposition others
like nursing assistants are rarely
licensed in other states and puts a
massive barrier in the way of entering
the field just for for reference
Massachusetts does not license uh
nursing assistants they require the
private certification that you can
attain so there's plenty of options
besides the heavy hand of licensure we
commend the governor for identifying
many licenses that have very little to
do with protecting consumer safety which
is the intent of licensure and instead
these licenses erect barriers to lower
income individuals from climbing uh the
economic ladder and seeking a better
life
many of the arguments for keeping
licenses like Landscape Architects
athletes agents Etc are based on federal
rules or insurance requirements for
certain jobs that can easily be replaced
by alternatives to licensure such as
private certifications or optional
government licensure
uh the current in the current economy we
think this is the absolute perfect time
to have a bold reform like this
eliminate these barriers attract new
workers to our state and and provide
economic growth uh so for these reasons
we urge the committee uh to uh keep the
governor's licensure proposal and it's
an app in its entirety uh and give
regulatory relief to Granite Staters uh
and and provide this relief thank you
thank you
did I say who was called Next I guess
I have
for people interested in the Midwife
Association of the Midwife Council I'll
call Rebecca price wood and then it also
has Kate Hartwell and Sherry Stevens if
all of you
I'll call you in succession hopefully if
one of you says everything that needs to
be said the others will Echo that thank
um it might not surprise you to hear
that we're opposed to hb2
um and we submitted a testimony online
um so I'm just going to pull tease out
the the parts that um I want to want you
to hear today one reason that we are
opposed um to how we're addressed as
midwives in hb2
is removing our Council and moving it to
an Advisory Board that's the way that it
affects us
um you know we've been a licensed
profession for over 40 years we've been
self-regulated
under the umbrella of oplc
and there have been hundreds of hours
that have been spent on these rules and
regulations and our statutes and how our
law gets played out to the New Hampshire
public and it has been agreed
um on what
what it takes to administer safe
Midwifery care in this state and I
wonder what about the budget makes that
no longer valid that it would change the
way that our laws are being administered
to the vulnerable populations of
pregnant people and newborns
the second thing I want to just say is
um
to the point of consultation as it
relates to the oplc executive director
which is an appointed position
managing
midwives in the state under consultation
with the board
noting that there is no definition in
this bill for consultation
and there is no requirement for
consultation with the advisory Council
in this bill
and um and that uh
again as another profession said that
outside experts are going to be brought
in and contracted to weigh in on matters
that our Council does as volunteers
uh there are other things that you'll
read in the testimony that was submitted
online but I'm going to yield to my
colleagues thank you thank you
who's next Kate or Sherry I'm Sherry
Stevens from Meredith New Hampshire and
I want to agree with what Rebecca said
and I just wanted to add that
um I would hope that they would take out
of the hb2 The Advisory making the New
Hampshire Mid River Council and advisory
as opposed to keeping the council the
way it has been and it also would reduce
our Council from six people which
included three midwives a obstetrician a
pediatrician and a consumer member and
it would make it just one position
either
pediatrician or obstetrician and we
don't think they are the same and only
have two midwives also I would ask that
you take out the part on 452 that
repeals the parts of our law because
we've worked really hard to make with
those three RSA 362 D in and I would
really appreciate not repealing that not
that I feel thank you and it's cater is
next
hello I'm Kate Hartwell I'm here as um
the board chair of the New Hampshire
Midway free Council I am going to Echo a
little bit of what my colleagues have
said but I'd like to outline for you the
concerns that the council has with hb2
New Hampshire is the Live Free or Die
State and few professions embody this
ideology better than New Hampshire
certified midwives to provide essential
background New Hampshire certified
midwives are experts on natural vaginal
delivery we serve the population of
low-risk mothers in New Hampshire who
choose to deliver either in their homes
or increase standing State licensed
birth centers
under our scope of practice we can order
all Labs ultrasounds and consults as
well as carry life-saving medications to
assist in childbirth and postpartum care
we do this under the regulations and
standards currently in place and hb2
threatens every aspect of our profession
including Public Safety
for the past few years the Midwifery
Council has welcomed administrative
assistance from the oplc we wish to
continue working with the oplc on the
administrative processes they already
help us with without losing the effect
of our professional expertise
hp2 proposes proposes to make the
Midwifery Council and advisory Council
the Midwifery Council strongly opposes
this for the following five reasons
number one by Shifting the council to an
advisory position hb2 effectively
consolidates power into the executive
director of the oplc to Define
qualifications for the practice of
Midwifery the teaching of Midwifery and
the scope of practice of Midwifery
including policies for professional
Direction and supervision
the executive director does not have the
expertise to Define any of these areas
the council acknowledges that the bill
proposes the executive director would
create these definitions in consultation
with the advisory Council under the law
however the executive director is not
required to consult or accept the
council's recommendations
this could hobble the profession
single-handedly point two the bill
proposes to reduce the number of council
members from six to three currently the
council is made up of three New
Hampshire certified midwives one
obstetrician one pediatrician and one
public member
the bill proposes The Advisory Council
constitute one obstetrician or
pediatrician and two New Hampshire
certified midwives this eliminates the
broad representation of the profession
and public serving on the council
and additional concern surrounding the
council's composition is the proposal
that the executive director selects
those members the executive director
does not have the expertise to select a
pediatrician or obstetrician who has
sufficient and relevant experience
working with midwives
I have to be very clear when I say many
Physicians do not understand our
practice at best or are actively
antagonistic at worst
number three the council exists in large
part to protect the public during
meetings the council sees complaints
your time is expired okay thank you so
much for your time
the rest of my statement as a handout
thank you
I think it could be stellato
from
the Department of Health of HH community
that will be followed by
I'm Carrie not Christy as the other
did I pronounce the name right no I'm
Carrie Duran but you called someone
before me and I
sorry go ahead okay great thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee um my name is Carrie Duran
it's a pleasure to be here today I visit
you from Wolfeboro and I'm joined today
by my daughter Katie Katie can you wave
right here she's 11 years old and she
has a developmental disability of down
syndrome I'm a single mom of three
amazing girls and I am also my
daughter's full-time caregiver and how
that goes above and beyond is she
receives In-Home Support due to her
disability which is an amazing program
that has helped our family so much
especially being a single mom but
unfortunately for the last almost three
years we've been unable to have staff
available I encourage you to support
hb1 increase the Medicaid rate so that
we can pay staff member is the wage that
they deserve to take care of our most
precious loved ones
there's not many people oh she's taking
a picture of me right now there's not
many people that I would leave to take
care of my daughter and when I do choose
someone when I do find that right person
I want to be able to pay them what
they're worth so I encourage you to
please support the Medicaid increase
rates and support hb1 thank you so much
for your time and have a wonderful
afternoon
thank you and sorry I didn't get the
right timing there that's that's all
right no worries all right is Christy
that
that was you
Debbie skyer
good afternoon thank you representative
Wilder my name is Debbie scary I'm the
president of the New Hampshire College
University Council I'd like to thank you
for the opportunity to speak before you
and I ask you to oppose the proposed
changes to the unique plan and the
establishment of a targeted Workforce
Development student debt relief program
hb2 proposes to make major changes to
the existing unique program the fees
generated to support the unique program
may vary from year to year based on
economic performance and that's why the
independent 529 commission which as
representatives from both the Senate and
the house that administers the program
developed both a scholarship fund as
well as a campus-based restricted
scholarship fund that assures through
good and bad Economic Times the money
will continue to be available to needy
New Hampshire students and their
families
100 of these funds are used right now
specifically for student scholarships
students will receive these scholarships
are not required to pay them this is
pure age in New Hampshire's students and
families not loans these scholarships
May mean the difference between a
student heading to college or deciding
that he or she simply cannot afford the
expense
it is a tremendously successful program
started in 1998 and to date has
dispersed 186 million dollars in
scholarship funds to needy New Hampshire
students over the years there has been
strong bipartisan support for The Unique
scholarship program and the legislature
has consistently turned back efforts to
redirect These funds for other purposes
and we hope that continues in this
legislative session
while student debt assistant is an
important objective
and Workforce Development is important
it should not come at the expense of New
Hampshire's student scholarship for
every million dollars taken from the
existing program up to a thousand
scholarships to New Hampshire's students
we have heard New Hampshire Business
Leaders discuss the need for a
well-educated Workforce and the vast
majority of high-paying jobs in our
state will require a degree
so the fact that we are considering
taking funds away from the scholarship
from New Hampshire students to earn a
college degree to and then pay for loans
makes it questionable policy
this change would result in the loss of
millions of dollars in student
scholarships for the most financially
vulnerable New Hampshire families
according to the National Association of
State grant and aid programs New
Hampshire ranks at the bottom for
tuition Aid to students number 50 so
when calculating the grant dollar amount
per population New Hampshire ranks 50
Vermont ranks 20 Main ranks 40 on the
same index the unique College savings
plan is the only long-term scholarship
program that exists in the state that
has a long-standing your time that's
expired thank you
thank you Wendy Stanley Jones will be
thank you
good afternoon chairman Weiler members
of the committee for transparency I am a
board of nursing member
please forgive my coughing I have
pneumonia
but this is too important for me to not
come
I respectfully disagree with AFP their
research is flawed this is my
professional
I'm here as a 39-year nurse 39-year
nurse concerned about adding more
unlicensed clinical staff to Health Care
if a CNA makes an error there's no
mechanism to report track re-educate
or deny them the ability to work
elsewhere
seen from the educational
system and clergy the detriment to the
public by not reporting unacceptable
Behavior
is that where we want to go
remember the medical technician who
stole patients fentanyl filled their
syringes with water
he also infected more than 40 people
and at least four states with hepatitis
C
UE he was unlicensed and unregulated
CNAs certified nursing assistants have
no database either Statewide or
nationally
confirm that they are in good standing
with and have not committed some harm
do you want an unlicensed person giving
medication
medications such as blood pressure
heart issues and Insulin are much more
dangerous if given incorrectly than
opioids
the CNA has minimal accountability
nurses are allowed to delegate duties to
unlicensed personnel
but that unlicensed person faces no
consequences if they do not follow the
guidelines
nurses by virtue of being licensed
are the ones who are responsible for
someone who doesn't have the answer that
who doesn't have to answer to the nurse
or anyone else for their actions
the mission mission of the nursing board
according to our website is to safeguard
Life Health the public wealthier people
of the state and protect the people from
unauthorized unqualified and improper
application of services by individuals
in the practice of Nursing
please consider removing licensed
nursing assistance from that list no
longer needing to be licensed
all of our safeties
we're not talking about planting a rose
bush we'll talk about you your family
and friends and our health thank you for
your time
Jim mishaw is going to talk about
assessing and Robert gagne is also going
to talk about the same thing so he'll be
thank you very much Mr chair and I also
asked leave of the chair to ask Lauren
Martin to also follow about gagne
because she's going to speak topic
say the name again Lauren Martin
I will look that up thank you thank you
thank you Mr chair and committee members
my name is Jimmy Shaw I'm the chief
assessor for the town of Hudson I rise
in opposition to sections 303 through
306 on House Bill 2.
that is seeking to make the board of
certified assessors from an independent
board to an Advisory Board
it also proposes to have the op oplc
director being the one person
responsible to appoint members to the
oacb and it also eliminates the public
membership slot on the assessing
certification board which I don't think
is well advised
the assessing certification board was
set up as an independent licensing board
on the house bill 1552 just in the last
session under the purview of the oplc
that was just nine months ago both
bodies of the legislature agreed on the
makeup of the independent board and the
governor signed the bill into law on
June 24 2022 many many hours were spent
on this legislation in 22.
involving all the stakeholders the
assessing Standards Board the oplc dra
the governor's office legislators the
general public
all of us had ample input into the
process and I'd hate to see that process
Jetsons under hb2 I would ask with The
Advisory board part to be stricken from
hb2 I don't even really think it should
go to house Edna the work was already
Robert gagne and then you said Warren
Chief assessor of the city of Manchester
what I'm here speaking today as a member
of the assessing Standards Board
I'll tell you that we have not met to
address this issue because it's come up
so quickly the assessing Standards Board
worked for months
to put together the proposal to create
the assessing certification board under
the oplc
and and designed it to be an independent
board
we were not consulted regarding changing
changing it to an Advisory Board it may
not be the wrong thing to do but it was
done without proper vetting we would ask
that this go to the Edna committee on to
be properly vetted before it's adopted
thank you
thank you and
oh say the name again it's Lauren Martin
l-o-r-e-n that's what I was looking for
that
um I represent Avatar and I also am on
the assessing Standards Board we worked
very diligently last year to form this
new assessing certification board which
would take that board away from the
Department of Revenue and put it under
the oplc a lot of work was done to to
that endeavor and then to just find this
out that our board would be an Advisory
Board
is a little concerning to our profession
there's many things that went into this
and to think that assessors are now
going to be certified under just an
Advisory board when our Duties are to
Value property across the state and the
property tax system is in Jeopardy if if
we're just under an Advisory Board I
think
I
Echo what gem and Bob said and I won't
waste a lot of time and I do appreciate
the opportunity to speak here today
thank you
well next call on
Brendan Williams
thank you Mr chairman honorable members
of the committee for the record Brendan
Williams president New Hampshire
Healthcare Association we represent
long-term care facilities including most
of the state's nursing homes and the
Cedar Crest Center for children with
disabilities and for a break we're not
here to testify on hb2 we're actually
here to testify hb1 and we are
respectfully requesting a 15 Medicaid
funding increase for nursing home care
and for the Cedar Crest Center for
children with disabilities we agree with
the CFI Advocates that our long-term
care system is teetering right now and
when we look at the fact that we have
facilities in our state right now with
wait lists of over 100 prospective
residents we have the nation's fourth
worst nursing home Staffing shortage
according to arp we have a healthy
Reliance upon out-of-state staffing
agencies a Reliance estate itself has
experienced it's got a seven point six
million dollar contract with a
California agency
to staff the New Hampshire veterans home
so all of these forces have combined
after the pandemic began to make things
very challenging for us in the request
that we have in terms of funding is not
out of line with what we have seen in
other states for example States like
Florida
Nebraska Pennsylvania Wisconsin just
over a one year period of time last year
raised grades by double digits as high
as 23 percent
in the state of Wisconsin more than 17
percent in Nebraska and Pennsylvania
Governor DeSantis signed a budget which
was over a 10 percent increase in just
one year's period of time in the State
of Florida and I think in terms of the
benefits of that if we look to the state
of Massachusetts and you heard testimony
earlier that a lot of our nurses are
double licensed here in New Hampshire
and also in Massachusetts and they go
across the border to opportunity in
Massachusetts well Massachusetts has
raised Medicaid raids its investment in
the nursing home Workforce by 33 since
the pandemic began
their Staffing shortage is only
one-sixth of what New Hampshire's is
right now we have over 60 percent of
facilities reporting shortages in
Massachusetts is 10.9 percent so I have
given you uh data on some of the
challenges that we're facing when you
look at Stratford well you look at
Sullivan County Nursing Home seeing a 2
000 increase in staffing agency costs
just between 2019 and 21 going from
about 70 cents per per resident day
October 14 per resident day you can see
that we are on an unsustainable
trajectory and we need your help in
order to stabilize recruit retain our
own Workforce thank you Mr chairman
thank you
thank you good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Steve Allen president of New Hampshire
Hospital Association I'm here
representing all of our state's
hospitals development of the state
budget is a key exercise in addressing
priorities in our state and we
appreciate the opportunity to share our
thoughts with you you have our written
testimonies and we'll go through it and
detail but I do want to touch on a few
key points
first we appreciate the governors across
the board Medicaid rate increases that
he's included in the budget but believe
we should be
considering much more targeted rate
increases in the areas of Behavioral
Health as well as for nursing home
providers long-term services and
supports and Home Care Providers one of
the greatest challenges facing hospitals
today is the inability to discharge
patients who are medically cleared to
move to their next level of care in a
nursing home Skilled Nursing Facility or
home care but are unable to because of
their own Staffing challenges or the
inability to timely transfer patients
from our hospital emergency departments
who are in a psychiatric crisis higher
Medicaid reimbursement rates would
create the stability and predictability
these providers need to be able to hire
and retain more staff to serve their
patients clients and residents
second the governor's budget proposes
significant reforms to our state's
licensing functions these are important
issues but we believe we are concerned
that the proposed changes to remove the
licensure for certain Health Care
professions is too much too soon and a
more thoughtful coordinated approach
should be taken to understand the direct
and unintended consequences of such
changes
third we do not support the delay and
implementation of the workforce
workplace violence prevention and
Healthcare workplace safety commission
included in house bill 2. and finally
just three weeks ago a Federal District
Court ruled that the state here in New
Hampshire is failing its responsibility
to care for our most vulnerable citizens
and must finally take action to come
into compliance and stop the practice of
boarding patients experiencing a
psychiatric crisis and hospital
emergency departments in response the
governor inserted language into the
Budget Trailer bill that enshrines
unfortunately a broken system in place
state law is very clear and has been
reinforced by multiple state and federal
court rulings when a patient is deemed
to be a danger him or herself or others
and a petition for involuntary emergency
admission is completed the patient is to
be committed to the State Mental Health
System and is to be transferred
immediately to a designated receiving
facility
the State closed two units at New
Hampshire hospital last year to do
staffing issues which resulted in
eliminating approximately 48 beds from
the system exacerbating the crisis by
further delaying care to patients in
need as of this February just a couple
of days ago more than 30 existing beds
remain unavailable to due to a lack of
Staffing in New Hampshire hospital
New Hampshire hospitals have been eager
to negotiate a short and long-term
binding solution with the state but
after multiple delays we were left with
no alternative but to seek further
relief through the courts to protect the
rights of patients in hospitals these
latest developments with House Bill 2
are just not acceptable The Proposal
language particularly that which removes
the requirement that patients be
transferred immediately is just not
acceptable this these Persians are wrong
and they should not be included in House
Bill too thank you very much for the
opportunity to share our thoughts be
happy to answer questions at a time
that's convenient for you thank you
thank you
John and Carrizo followed by Jamie
shagnon both will speak on Meals on
Wheels
s okay
all right Lindsay
[Music]
it's Courtney like the name thank you
don't have good handwriting
uh for the record I'm Lindsay Courtney
I'm the executive director of the New
Hampshire office of professional Ace
insurance certification
we've certainly heard a lot today a lot
of concerns regarding the governor's
proposed licensing reforms and house
bill 2. but what we haven't heard is a
comprehensive we haven't heard a broad
overview about the governor's plan for
comprehensive licensure reform and what
changes the agency and the boards would
see as a result at the agency we've
really been diving into House Bill 2 and
we are prepared to offer Finance for the
various divisions
to come forward and conduct the
presentation of what is contained if
they're in for example regarding nursing
assistance you've heard today of the
need to regulate nursing assistance and
I agree with that what you didn't care
is that there's a federal registry that
already requires that we register
nursing assistants and we already do so
those are the types of things that I
think we would be able to bring forward
with more than three minutes to spare
and I just wanted to leave you with that
and if you are interested we'd be happy
to partner with you on that thank you
I can't quite read the name it could be
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for taking my testimony and I
also appreciate your stamina on a day
like this
I'm Alan rates since 1991 I've owned a
home in Plainfield New Hampshire and I'm
employed and represent the Hanover Co-op
food stores and auto service centers the
Hanover Co-op was founded in 1936 by 17
local families
today our homegrown business delivers 88
million dollars to the local economy
thanks to the work of our 350 employees
my concern is the negative impact
housing is having on businesses all
across the state
years of work by citizens and
legislators have brought you to this
moment
the funding request before you in hb1
are the culmination of extensive work
Fair debate and balance deliberation
as you prepare to take action I
specifically urge support for funding
for the prioritized need requests and
DHHS for homeless services
funding of the affordable housing fund
funding for invest NH
and funding for the historic housing tax
credit
allow me to highlight just one of the
the average age of New Hampshire
residents is rising rapidly which makes
Health Care for Seniors all the more
important
yet even though we have top-notch health
care facilities nearby the lack of
housing means fewer nurses and doctors
to perform Critical Care
provide service to veterans
or give timely treatment to those
suffering from chronic disease
medical facilities and Clinics across
our region are not understaffed by
choice the Crux of the issue is housing
please retain the budget points I have
listed
they are Homegrown Solutions that are
right for New Hampshire right now thank
you very much
thank you
did I pronounce the name right Esther
Connors from Portsmouth
and master Kennedy of Portsmouth but I
also am the director of student service
for the Guilford public schools and I
also teach graduate classes and special
needs for Plymouth University and I'm
here today because
I'm very concerned about all the work
I'm doing with our children with
disabilities in the public school every
day and I've been doing it for 30 plus
years and then they go to the local
agency at 22 and the services are just
not there for them
and I ask you to support this bill as a
public school educator so my work does
not go unfounded
and I also think that if there's any
chance in the future
that we actually add more money because
I'm very concerned about our autism
population in particular and our other
students who will have a lot of needs
when they reach adulthood and our
agencies really need the funding to
contribute
I would also like to add that I do have
children currently sitting in
ers
because there's no mental health values
so I would encourage you all to look at
that and move forward on seeing how we
can help our population of children that
have mental health concerns and what we
can do to support them
again I thank you for your service and I
thank you for your time
thank you Lori McIntyre followed by Sue
press the red button there you go
thank you board chair and members of the
house finance committee my name is Lori
McIntyre I am the administrator at
Hanover Hill Healthcare Center in
Manchester I've been there for almost 25
years and I am also currently the board
chair of the New Hampshire Healthcare
Association my facility is one of the
few remaining family owned and operated
skilled nursing facilities in the state
and we take great pride in the care that
we provide to our residents but we need
the state's help to continue our
expenses have grown exponentially since
the pandemic although we have
significantly increased our own staff
wages we have been forced to supplement
with agency nursing staff with an annual
expense of 1.2 million dollars last year
the lack of adequate Medicaid funding
limits our ability to further attract
competent and dedicated Workforce in
such a tight labor market inflation has
caused caused significant increases in
general expenses medical supplies food
electricity everything that we see in
the community as well reimbursement just
isn't keeping Pace we have turned away
patients needing our care from acute
care hospitals and members of our
community because we must limit census
to meet our staffing capabilities today
62 percent of my residents in our
building are comprised of Medicaid
residents daily Medicaid reimbursement
further reduced by the budget neutrality
Factor does not cover the cost of care
for these residents
we respectfully ask that you provide for
a 15 Medicaid rate increase that will
help us to address the extraordinary
costs and give us the resources to
compete in a drastically changed job
market thank you
thank you
Sue did I pronounce her name right
it's a tricky one it's wall power
um my name is Sue walthour I live in
Keene and in the spirit of full
disclosure I'm the legislative liaison
for monomic developmental Services the
area agency of region 10. I'm presenting
today's private citizen additionally I
work as a direct support professional
and have since I was 19. we won't
mention how many years that's been I
currently have a client that I support
on a part-time basis
I ask that you support the funding in
House Bill 1 and House Bill 2. my
current plan participates in a day
program that takes him into the
community of Keene where he continues to
learn social skills and interact with
peers and community members he and
others can attend the day program only
if there are staff to transport and
support them you're probably aware and
you've heard already today but again
dsps are some of the lowest paid people
in the workforce 13.50 an hour and even
lower in some cases and these are adults
these are not 13 year olds these
potential workers can go to a local
coffee or Burger Shop and make far more
money than they would doing some of the
most important work any of us can do
caring for fellow human beings
in some cases staff who support
individuals are making less than the
person they support
often day programs go unstaffed and
clients must spend the day at home with
a care provider who might have had to
leave a job as there is no one to care
for their loved ones and I'd just like
to mention that we would typically have
far more individuals or fan and families
presenting testifying today but because
of our dramatically decreased Workforce
they just could not get here they are
able to provide testimony online for
that we are grateful but we certainly
like to have people here in person
we support hb1 and hb2 and fund
community-based supports and services
for people with Developmental and other
disabilities and a Medicaid rate
increase to support our very important
Workforce thank you
thank you Brian Harlow followed by Kim
buck
can you hear me okay yes
chairman Weiler and committee members my
name is Brian Harlow and I'm here to
speak in support of a fully funded
alcohol fund
included in the budget
for anywhere with the alcohol fund is
and why it's vital to us as parents
advocates
those in recovering taxpayers here it is
a bill was signed into law in 2020
establishing that five percent of gross
sales of alcohol in New Hampshire be set
aside
to fund prevention treatment and
Recovery historically however
the alcohol fund has been tragically
underfunded
and just so you know in 2024-25
that figure is estimated to be 11
million
today however March 13 2023 is my 30th
clean silver anniversary and I'm 50
years old so I can tell you something
evidence-based treatment works and I'm
living proof
when I was desperate to live and needed
treatment my parents Blue Cross Blue
Shield
was the key to get me into expedited
treatment and Rehab
today the alcohol fund is trying
desperately to meet the needs of those
not so lucky as I was to enter treatment
return to their families lives in the
workforce
please
ensure that New Hampshire
remains committed to prevention
treatment
and Recovery by fully funding the
alcohol fund it's not only the right
thing to do it's also the law thank you
good afternoon my name is Ken Block
thank you for for time to speak with you
I am the executive director director of
the New Hampshire Coalition of recovery
residences I support everything Mr
Harlow just had to say I work with homes
that serve people in recovery
we also request that you fully fund the
alcohol fund
it has supported the New Hampshire
Coalition of recovery residences to
bring best practices to Recovery Home
operators for the past three plus years
three and a half years in that time
we've certified 85 houses that
represents over 1100 beds right now
um it's a lot of work we put a lot of
time in and we think we do a pretty darn
good job at a very low price to the
state
the governor's commission has a great
group of people of a lot of non-profits
and a lot of organizations that work to
support those who are in recovery they
also try to work on prevention and
treatment
it's a good team working together it
deserves to be fully funded
our state statistics show that what New
Hampshire has been doing is working when
you compare the statistics to the rest
of the nation
we're doing a little bit better
it's not the time to cut any of the
funding it's the time to fully support
the alcohol fund thank you for your time
today
thank you
good afternoon honorable chair members
of the committee my name is Alyssa Eng
and I'm the coordinator for Merrimack
County Drug Court
I am also here to ask you to fund the
alcohol fund the five percent level
one of the programs that the alcohol
fund funds is the community housing
program the community housing program
provides stable housing for participants
of all our drug courts across the state
the community housing program has
increased our overall graduation rate by
30 percent I've watched a client go from
living in a storage unit to living in
his own apartment because of CHP support
right now 36 out of our 45 let in
participants have benefited from the
community housing program and 13 out of
our 21 graduates since the start of CHP
can contribute their successes to the
I asked one of my participants to write
a few words I would like to share with
you about the community housing program
and how it has contributed to his
success and his pending graduation from
our program in May of this year
to whom it may concern the community
housing program has been instrumental to
my sobriety from the moment I was deemed
eligible to receive funding the number
of ways I have benefited from this
program are measurable today I have just
over a year sober and I'm and I am in
Phase five of the Merrimack County Drug
Court and flourishing in the sober
Community from the outside looking in it
may seem like all I was given from CHP
was funds for a place to live truly it
was much more to summarize I was given a
new life the community housing program
is the foundation of my life without
this Foundation I never would have had a
chance to stand up and fight my
addiction
recipients and there are many all over
the state I can confidently say the
community housing program has saved many
lives including mine this is just one of
many success stories and the community
housing program is just one of many
programs supported by the alcohol fund I
want to thank the honorable chair and
the members of the committee for their
time and consideration on continuing to
fully fund the alcohol fund that will
help so many and build back our state
that has been suffering under the drug
crisis my colleagues and team members
work so hard every day to fight thank
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Mark
Peterson I am the President and owner of
Interim HealthCare of the Northeast
based out of Manchester a third
generation
family owned and operated Home Health
agency and we provide private duty
nursing to New Hampshire's Home Care
recipients
Medicaid private duty nursing is a
program in New Hampshire which places
ICU level of nurses in the homes of New
Hampshire's most medically fragile Home
Care patients and keeps those patients
out of the more expensive environments
such as hospitals
Interim HealthCare has been serving New
Hampshire's Medicaid private duty
nursing patients across the state for
the last 44 years and we have never in
the history of our organization had a
more difficult time finding and placing
nurses in the homes of these private
duty nursing patients
we serve dozens of private duty nursing
patients each day and are providing just
a fraction of the hours these patients
have been authorized to remain safely in
their homes
New Hampshire has and continues to lose
valuable our valuable population of
Highly qualified nurses that would
otherwise care for these patients to
other care settings in other states such
as Massachusetts as a result of the
underfunded program
we are here today to explain these
private duty nursing rates need to be
increased so we can compete with
Hospital wages and Mass health
we are requesting a 40 rate increase to
the private duty nursing rates
we ask that the Medicaid budget be
increased by 2.6 million in fiscal year
24 and 5.3 million fiscal year 25 in
general funds to assure that these
patients get the care they need at home
we also ask that the home health aid
reimbursement rates for the Medicaid
State Plan services and CFI Services be
brought up to the same level as title 10
uh as a title 10 program thank you very
much for your time
thank you
Dr Michelle half followed by Michelle St
John
good afternoon uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak today my name is Dr
Michelle Haff I am the President of the
New Hampshire Association of
naturopathic doctors and we are opposed
to sections 454 to 465 of hb2 which aim
to remove our current naturopathic Board
of examiners and create a naturopathic
Advisory Board of examiners
our our organization represents
naturopathic doctors licensed in New
Hampshire where we have been licensed
for 28 years
we have a large scope of practice and we
can act as primary care providers
um naturopaths in New Hampshire diagnose
and treat thousands of New Hampshire
residents with low cost low risk Natural
Therapeutics
in addition we can and do prescribe
Pharmaceuticals when necessary and our
approach to Health Care can improve
patient quality of life in deeply
meaningful ways not to mention reduce
the financial burden to the Health Care
system
our organization has deep concerns about
the proposed changes in hb2 which would
change the structure of our current
naturopathic Board of examiners to a
naturopathic Advisory Board of examiners
this proposed change would entail
shifting oversight of our profession
from a board of our peers and a public
member to oversight by a single person
the executive director of oplc
the proposed Advisory Board which would
be comprised of three naturopathic
doctors as opposed to the current four
naturopathic doctors and a public member
would not have final approval approval
over new rules or repeal of rules or
changes to our formulary which is a list
of medications naturopathic doctors May
prescribe in New Hampshire some of which
are controlled substances
final decisions on these matters would
fall exclusively to the executive
director of oplc who is not a medical
provider with any knowledge of the
nuances of the practice of naturopathic
medicine or prescribing Pharmaceuticals
and these are very very complicated
matters we believe these proposed
changes pose a risk to Public Safety
when the sole purpose of oplc is to
protect the public
the current naturopathic Board of
examiners is an efficient body that is
effective in overseeing the practice of
naturopathic medicine due to the small
number of licensees in our state and
very low number of complaints 11
complaints in five years to be exact it
costs oplc a very small amount of money
to in administrative costs to support
our board and therefore we would like to
maintain our current board structure
we feel the executive director of oplc
is not qualified to have final say over
adopting and repealing rules or making
changes to our prescriptive formulary
putting a layperson in charge of
decision making about complicated
medical practices who has no knowledge
of medicine pharmacology or
Pharmaceuticals poses a grave threat to
Public Safety therefore we respectfully
request that sections 454 time is
expired thank you appreciate your time
thank you
followed by
Michaela Demeter
thank you chairman and members of the
committee my name is Michelle St John
and I'm here today on behalf of Northern
Human Services one of the 10 non-profit
organizations across the state that
provide services and supports for
individuals who experience a
developmental disability or an acquired
brain disorder in co-ops Carol and upper
Grafton counties
I'm here today to provide testimony on
behalf of the individuals and families
we serve that is in support of funding
for developmental disability services
and the proposed Medicaid rate increase
I'd like to read one of those letters of
support right now and then submit others
for your additional
reading thank you
dear chairman Weiler and members of the
house finance committee I don't envy
your task I'm sure that there are many
causes that deserve taxpayer support I
want to put my concern in my concern
that you fully fund community-based
supports for people with intellectual
disabilities my daughter Maya had lots
of needs she had medical educational and
social needs the most stressful need was
getting caregivers to watch her before
and after school
she was an escape artist and without
supervision would find ways out she had
little to no awareness of danger we
lived close to Lake Winnipesaukee why
was getting caregivers stressful I had
enough hours in our In-Home Support
budget but besides those crazy hours
that I needed coverage the pay rate that
I could offer them was ridiculously low
please support an increase in salaries
for direct support professionals
in order to hire people I had to
supplement that salary from the state
thankfully I was in a position to do
that but most are not
person could literally make more money
working at Dunkin Donuts with less
stress
being a direct supports professional is
something people do because they are
called to that
it is unfair to take advantage of that
by not paying them what they are worth
I appreciate the time and attention to
this letter and I've included a picture
of Maya and her caregiver to emphasize
that these are real people with real
genuine needs thank you Emily James
Wolfeboro thank you
thank you McKellar de meter followed by
I learned members of the house finance
committee my name is Michaela Demeter
and I serve as a member of the Dover
School Board though I do not speak for
the school board with these comments I'm
also a signatory on the letter I just
presented written by the New Hampshire
school funding fairness project and
signed by more than 150 locally elected
leaders who represent taxpayers in over
70 towns and cities across New Hampshire
including 12 colleagues from my home
city of Dover I'm here today to
encourage you to fully fund our public
education system by correcting
long-standing inequities and gaps and
fulfilling the state's constitutional
requirement to provide all students with
an adequate education
according to data from the U.S Census
Bureau New Hampshire has the lowest
percentage of State funding for public
education of any state in the country so
local property taxpayers are forced to
Bear over 70 percent of the total cost
of public education far exceeding the
national average of 44 and a half
percent
being the lowest in the nation is
wonderful if we're comparing violent
crime statistics or unemployment rates
but it's embarrassing when we're talking
about education
the commission to study school funding
established by your legislative body
concluded in its final report that quote
the state's current estimated cost for
an adequate education is not
reproducible by any empirically based
approach end quote no school district
can provide appropriate public education
to its pupils using the state's average
contribution of just
4773 dollars per student because
taxpayers make up the funding Gap left
by the state New Hampshire school
districts are divided into halves and
have-nots based on wildly varying
equalized property values in each town
or city and wildly varying tax rates as
a result sadly quote the commission
found that lower student outcomes are
directly related to lower total spending
per student which is in turn related to
lower Property valuations New
Hampshire's Baseline adequacy Aid
provides a small fraction of the true
cost of Education as evidenced by
significantly higher expenses for
reported in every single School District
in our state you have an opportunity to
fix these problems by increasing both
Baseline adequacy Aid and targeted aid
for vulnerable populations in doing so
you will ensure students in every New
Hampshire school district have access to
the best possible public education while
also providing real property tax relief
for taxpayers in every corner of the
state
strong well-funded public education is
the most important asset for the future
of New Hampshire and its citizens I
encourage you to improve our education
funding model and use the guidance
provided by the commission to study
school funding their thorough and
extensive recommendations are only as
good as the actions that result from
them thank you again for your time and
consideration today
thank you
William Walker followed by Mary
Fitzpatrick
thank you chairman wheeler and the
members of the house finance committee
for the opportunity to speak today my
name is Will Walker I live in the hot
list with my wife and my 23 year old son
with autism I'm also the legislative
liaison for our Gateway Community
Services but I'm here speaking today as
a family member
I'm asking for your support for the
developmentally developmental
disabilities budget as well as oppose
Medicaid wave increases my wife son and
I are part of a team this team also
includes a direct support professional
and a case manager through the gateways
Community Services
through the support of this team of
through the support of development
disabilities waiver this team works
together to design Implement and
maintain a service plan that helps my
son receive the services that he needs
as a result of these Services he's a
growing and contributing to society he
has a job of Meals on Wheels he
Volunteers in the community and this
benefits not only him and growing but
also benefits the people that work with
him okay so it's nice to have inclusion
in the community so we expose people to
people with disabilities and also people
with disabilities that get exposed to
the community due to the work for a
shortage that we had it took months to
put this team together it was really
hard to find a qualified direct service
professional and Pace manager to build
this this team and we our direct support
professional Molly and our case manager
Christy Don they are this wonderful
caring committed skilled people and we
want to keep that team together
the developmental disabilities budget
and the proposed Medicaid rate increase
will help keep them together
if this budget is at risk or the the
rate increases are at risk it puts this
team at risk it helps make my team or
chairs our team apart and the person
that is impacted by that is my son
okay so please help keep our team
together please help more teams get
like-minded foreign for other people by
supporting the developmental
disabilities budget and the proposed
Medicaid rate increase thank you for
your time today
thank you
David Trumbull
followed by Jessica
Carter
thank you Mr chairman my name is David
Trumbull I'm here on behalf of the Kent
Street Coalition today to talk about
education funding I have a couple of
points to make first of all I'd like to
go back to the New Hampshire
constitution in the Claremont decision
there's been a lot of confusion about
what the Claremont decision really held
I'd like to just reinforce three key
points from that decision first it is
the state of New Hampshire's duty to
provide an adequate education to every
child not the town's Duty under our
constitution it is the state's Duty
second this we have to provide an
adequate level of funding to every
single child in this state and third
according to the Supreme Court this Duty
applies to the public schools not to any
other schools those are additional
options but the requirement goes to the
public schools this Duty has been on the
plate of our governor and our
legislature for 30 years and we have
never adequately dealt with this it is
time that we actually do this the
Supreme Court made this decision because
the importance of an educated citizenry
number two the governor's budget is
devastating in the long term to the poor
schools the governor increases the
adequacy amount by eight hundred dollars
and then which is about 100 million
dollars increase and he increases efas
by 50 million dollars that's 150 million
dollar increase where does that come
from this year is paid for by the
Surplus it covers up any losses but the
long-term funding for the Governor's
increases comes by eliminating the
stabilization grants which is 157
million the relief date for 18 million
now there's an offset with a little bit
of extraordinary aid but if you add up
what the poor towns lose and what the
poor towns get back it's a net loss of
112 million dollars per year now that's
going to be phased in over 10 years but
the legacy of Governor sununu's
education budget is that the poor towns
in this state are going to lose a
hundred and 10 million dollars now what
does that look like in the real world
the 20 poorest towns get about four
thousand dollars per child from the
stabilization fund the 70 poorest towns
get over 40 percent of their funding
from State funding in 10 years these
towns are going to lose four thousand
dollars if they're only spending fifteen
thousand that's all they can come up
with from their tax base now they're
down to eleven thousand dollars in
today's dollars you cannot run a school
on eleven thousand dollars I'll ask you
to look at what the town of Allenstown
did the school board there said what
could we afford if all we have is what
the state gives us for adequacy they end
up with this is their formula elementary
schools have 29 children in the
classroom middle schools 37 and they had
to get rid of all busing no educational
supplies no textbooks no Chromebooks no
clubs no Sports nobody who could fix
plumbing or heating no grounds work no
snow plowing no summer programs no food
services no art music physical Ed no
Behavior teacher no reading specialist
no ell no guidance counselors no Street
crossing guards half the nurses are gone
no substitute teachers and significant
cuts to special ed budgets that's the
future of New Hampshire schools for the
poor towns if you adopt the budget the
way it is you have a concert sometimes
Jessica Carter and I'm from Nashua I am
the crsw Certified Recovery support
worker on the New Hampshire Board of
Licensing for Alcohol and Other Drug use
professionals
and just so I don't get cut off at the
end I'll let you know that even though
we're opposed to hb2 we are here in
support of any potential recommendations
by from Edna to retain the bill for
further study
so the laidac board already administers
four credentials with individual scopes
of practice Preparatory
requirements and ethical nuances
consolidating it along with psychology
into the board of mental health practice
ignores the fundamental differences in
the focus
experiential learning and educational
underpinnings as well as ethical
requirements of the practice of
substance use disorder treatment that a
generalist board could not be expected
to have the specific knowledge to
adequately understand
for the laidac board the voice of the
distinct credentials will be lost on the
Consolidated board as the as only the
highest level of Licensing that M laidac
will be retained so my position the
Certified Recovery support worker would
be gone
the substance use treatment profession
will have a lone voice on the board that
is already heavily weighted to the
Mental Health Professions which approach
the work with different priorities
training and focus
licensees and particularly the latex and
crsws whose scopes of practice are
vastly different than those of mental
health providers who must face the board
in ethics hearings will find themselves
deprived of the right to be heard by a
jury of peers as that jury will have no
experience in the unique requirements
and challenges of their specific
professions
the laidac board has a structured career
ladder one of which I intend on trying
to climb myself
um
that allows the different levels of
licensor and certification to build upon
each other thereby facilitating and
incentivizing the development of the
substance use disorder Workforce
consolidating of these boards raises the
risk of damaging this carefully crafted
career ladder as it won is educational
and experiential experiential design is
fundamentally fundamentally different
and two it fails to define the substance
use disciplines while simultaneously
excluding the laidac and crsw from the
definition of mental health disciplines
there is a fundamental loss of identity
of the substance use disorder profession
by making it more making more I'm sorry
making it more one more member of the
board of mental health practice the
licensees and certificate holders under
the laidac board are sud providers some
of whom hold us a specialty in the
practice of mental health treatment
this is intrinsically different for all
the other professional professions
grouped under the Mental Health Board
where focus is on practice of mental
health while some of them hold a
specialty in substance use treatment
the laidac board is a member of the
international certification and
reciprocity Consortium the board of
mental health practice is not nor would
its other professions be eligible under
these rules so this puts hundreds of
licenses in the state of New Hampshire
under the laidac board at risk for
losing recipes reciprocity in 42 States
14 countries the Air Force the Navy the
Army your time is expired
so thank you I'm getting confused on my
cards your name
Jessica Carter got it right there's
another one very like mine earlier thank
you Kate fry is next followed by Forrest
om today
um uh so I have handed in our written
testimony as as well as a storybook On
the Alcohol fund we have several items
in the budget that we are highlighting
but since I just have a few minutes I
will quickly go through this as as
quickly as possible but I will leave our
testimony with you
um as you heard today uh new Futures and
other Advocates are strongly in support
of a fully funded alcohol fund uh new
Futures has always advocated for a the
fully funding of the alcohol fund since
it was created in 2000. five that's just
five percent of gross profits from uh
generated from alcohol sales in this
state
and they are to be used for the
Governor's commission
um on other Alcohol and Other Drugs for
programming and services for context
five percent of gross profit was
estimated at 10.3 million in 2021
dropping the bucket to the records sales
they made Liquor Commission made of 801
million in that same year if the
alcoholic is alcohol fund is an
Innovative fiscally responsible Common
Sense approach to a real need in New
Hampshire which you heard about uh the
fund in the past has either been
underfunded or diverted most recently in
2018 per the passage of SB 313 the
alcohol fund statute although increased
to five percent was diverted to be used
for the state share the Medicaid
expansion uh requirement this left a
hole in the budget fortunately the
hospitals did backfill those funds
that's until that uh agreement ends in
December 2023 so we asked that we fully
fund the alcohol fund we also fund
Medicaid expansion but we use the
original intent of the law which is for
that five percent of gross profits to be
used for the Governor's commission
funding you have a storybook of some of
the great programs that this has allowed
to be funded quickly too we ask that the
committee look at the agency budget
submissions for children's Behavioral
Health
Farmers WIC benefit and division of
Public Health Services and the home
visiting formula grant they asked for
additional Appropriations mainly for
maintenance of effort and we'd like to
see that restored in the budget going
along we also support efforts for a
system of care for adults and elderly
and Adult Services and lastly we have
some of the same convert uh concerns
Voice tonight around the office of
professional licensure and certification
in-house Bill too we as at the
commission looks at that very closely
has a separate public hearing and make
the decisions that work best for the
residents of New Hampshire
thank you for your time
thank you Forrest Bowden freed fought
hi it's been a while
um
hi Mr chairman and members of a how are
you today my name is Forest Broadway
uh please support house bills one and
two Sunday four people with
Developmental and other disabilities and
also a
Medicaid red inquiries
um I live in Concord New Hampshire
of direct care support workers and
funding make it possible for me to live
um I am an active editor at project
search
um and as a training program for Ed
Harrisville have entered chefs and um
and it's very exciting
um I am also an active member in my
community and I enjoy it
um I currently have employment and I
work at Domino's and
um I have a um whether they all right
editly and and supporting I'm able to
answer
um uh please find services for people
with disabilities and a medicated right
and praise thank you
thank you
Maggie Fogerty followed by Jennifer
sarter
good evening Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for this opportunity
to speak my name is Maggie Fogerty I'm
the New Hampshire program director for
the American friends service committee
I'm a member of the New Hampshire
Coalition for a people's budget which is
a Grassroots Coalition of Faith
organizations and Progressive groups
advocating for a budget that invests in
all New Hampshire people our communities
and the planet
and funding that those Investments by
taxing the wealthy and corporations to
pay their fair share so that
collectively we have a fair and adequate
pool of resources so that we're not
pitting affordable housing against
public education or mental health
supports against
a much overdue raise for our state
workers or for investments in renewable
energy
but I'm actually here today on behalf of
the New Hampshire immigrant rights
Network so I'll use my remaining time to
make
to make to lift up our key point which
is that we are strenuously opposed to
the aspect of hb2 page 34 line seven
that would create the northern border
Alliance program
this appears to be an attempt to use New
Hampshire taxpayer funds for federal
immigration enforcement activities
we urge members of the house finance
committee to emphatically reject this
program as ill-conceived politically
motivated
anti-immigrant and gross misuse of
taxpayer dollars
hb2 enacts a new law enforcement
initiative that would be codified as the
northern border Alliance program to be
funded annually by more than 1.4 million
dollars of non-lapsing taxpayer funds
the language in hb2 is very short on
specifics but it describes officers
engaged in funded activities would be
relieved of taking calls for services
absent on Emergency
in other words the work contemplated by
this legislation diverts local law
enforcement officers from their primary
commitments to the communities they
serve without any explanation of why we
need this additional Alliance program
over the past year the Swanton sector of
the Customs and Border Protection has
seen a market increase in unauthorized
border crossings
but it's not clear this is the sector
that includes it's a 248 mile border
only 58 miles of which are in New
Hampshire it's not clear that that
there's any activity happening at our
border that necessitates this uh
investment
CDP hasn't published any data segregated
by state and Governor sununu hasn't
cited any examples of apprehensions in
New Hampshire and all of the instances
quoted in the media pertain to Vermont
and New York
to fund the northern border Alliance
will undo Decades of work by immigrant
Community leaders and Advocates to build
relationships with law enforcement times
expired at all levels please don't erode
Jennifer sarter followed by Brandy
cousin
hi my name is Dr Jennifer Sartori and I
am representing the board of Podiatry
we are
opposed to the HBQ proposal to merge the
board of Podiatry with the Board of
Medicine
um well I understand that this proposal
may seem like a logical way to
streamline operations and save costs I
believe it will have a serious negative
consequence for the practice of Podiatry
as well as for the people of the State
of New Hampshire Podiatry is a
specialized field of medicine that
requires a unique set of skills and
expertise as such that I just undergo
extensive training and the diagnosis and
treatment of foot and ankle disorders
by merging the board of Podiatry Board
of Medicine we risk diluting the
expertise of podiatrists and reducing
their ability to provide Specialized
Care to their patients the two degrees
are different as well we hold the DPM
while
the Board of Medicine members hold an MD
or a do
furthermore emerging the two boards
would likely result in the loss of focus
on specific needs and issues facing the
podiatric community
we Face unique challenges and concerns
that are distinct from those of other
medical professionals and we need a
dedicated board that can address this
and provide guidance and support
finally I'm concerned that merging the
two boards will result in account of
lack of accountability
we need a clear and accessible process
for licensure regulation and discipline
if the two boards were merged may become
more difficult for podiatrists to
navigate these processes and they may be
subject to Less Direct oversight and
accountability
so for these reasons I urge you to
reconsider the proposal to merge the
board of Podiatry with the Board of
Medicine I appreciate your time and
thank you
good day chairman why we're members of
the finance committee my name is Brandon
custom
and I am the president of New Hampshire
Society of the radiologic technologist
it's a Professional Organization founder
for the express purpose of enhancing
through education and advocacy the
proper and safe delivery of Medical
Imaging and Therapy Services
in light of transparency I'm also on the
Merck Ward and through the oplc
I'm also a New Hampshire Delegate for
the National American Society for RTS
today we welcome the opportunity to
appear before you today during these
hearings and commend the New Hampshire
General Corp for its attention to this
very important subject
we are respectfully asking the committee
to strike section 431 of hb2 that would
repeal Bert licensure since its
Discovery in 1895 X radiation has
produced and provided enormous benefits
to society primarily as a life-saving
tool in the diagnosis and treatment of
disease
the use of the X-ray in the Medical Arts
has grown into a sophisticated science
that plays a major role in the
assessment of virtually all diseases
if licensure is repealed New Hampshire
would be one of only six states that do
not have education or certification
standards in place for persons
performing Medical Imaging examinations
the production of radiation as used in
the practice of medicine is an
invaluable tool in the diagnosis and
treatment of disease even so the use of
radiation in medicine is not without
risks and an inherent potential of
biological damage to healthy tissue
any exposure to ionizing radiation
however small the dose increases the
risk of developing cancer of leukemia
cataracts blood disorders birth defects
and developing fetuses any unnecessary
exposure therefore produces a risk
without benefit to the patient
if mert is repealed health care
facilities and physician offices in New
Hampshire using X-ray equipment would
not be under any statutory obligation to
ascertain or require any credentials or
specified education of the person
employed to operate the Imaging
equipment literally anyone off the
street could be hired it could be
potentially
exposing
patients with dangerous radiation
without sufficient knowledge of its
application the operator has the
potential to produce biological damage
not only to the patient but to
themselves as well the state and federal
level's significant steps have been
taken to protect Public Health through
manufacturing regulations for electronic
products such as X-ray and other Medical
Imaging equipment
however like your car the operator
determines the use and abuse of this
equipment no one would permit no one
would permit their car with all of its
safety features to be driven by someone
who has never been taught to drive
and yet we would allow untrained
operators of Medical Imaging equipment
to expose the patient's radiation that
can affect your times expired
Generations thank you for your time
thank you
hello my name is Sharon borst at this
point I believe I should bid you all a
good evening hi thank you for staying
thank you for allowing me to come and
speak today in opposition of hb2 section
431. as I said my name is Sharon borst I
am a registered right out radiography
technologist with the state of New
Hampshire
and as with everyone in the medical
field we are short staffed and it was
imperative to me today and my thing that
I come today to speak to you
State licensure is important so that we
hold Imaging Professionals to a higher
standard a standard of education and a
standard of safety without education you
directly compromise safety safety is
compromised by directly increasing the
patient dose that can lead to
misdiagnoses or missing critical
findings
you increase those to staff that will
increase long-term effects
and as as well as other licensers have
people that have disrespected the
um
standards that have been set forth and
have not been licensed and caused harm
to other people such as David kajkowski
who gave several patients hepatitis from
diverting medications
um
please understand that in the X-ray
field we are not just in your emergency
room when you break your finger or your
arm where your or
we're in your hospital room
we're there for you to do Dynamic
studies to see how your body actually
and how
so please stop the repeal
of the licensure for medical
professionals thank you
thank you
Damon Burke Stratford
I'm the chair of the board of natural
scientists so we oversee wetlands and
soil scientists and we appreciate the
update from representative McGuire on
the on the
including us off the list or taking us
off the list so I'm going to try to keep
this quick I already submitted testimony
but we
we protect the natural environment and
the public so it's an important role and
we've heard back from a lot of
Representatives and folks all around so
we're very encouraged by what's going on
um
we classify delineate and map wetlands
and soil resources to help development
by if we're not a board and there's no
certified Wetland scientists it would
actually slow down the process and
require Des to do more Army Corps so
take away
a lot of the control of local boards and
the other thing is if we were taken away
it would put a burden on local
municipalities which have us written
down as Wetland and soil scientists and
their regulation rely on us so those are
all very important things and certainly
engineerings and surveyors a lot rely on
us and specific to our certification we
have an exam written exam and then a
field exam so it really puts the
emphasis on New Hampshire what we do so
we actually take applicants out in the
field and test them so that's that's
about all I'm gonna do and I know
there's other uh organizations around
the country but it's sort of like uh do
we want federal or we want local so by
being local in New Hampshire we're
really
certifying individuals that are doing
good work for uh developers local
municipalities and the state and Des so
I'm just going to keep it short and
thank you for your time appreciate it
thanks for your patience Steve Rancourt
followed by
I guess Steve Rancourt isn't here
hi thank you I'm Kim Rooney from
Hillsborough New Hampshire and I'd like
to thank you for the opportunity to be
here today it's truly a privilege
privilege and I really truly
respect and take this very seriously and
I'm happy to be here
I'm asking today for you to support the
developmental Services budget and the
proposed Medicaid rate increase
I'm here because of my daughter
Caitlyn who is 30 years old I'd like to
tell you a little bit about her
she doesn't have a true diagnosis we've
been searching for 30 years and just a
couple weeks ago again we're told come
back in five years we'll keep trying
which is non-verbal has poor chewing
swallowing skills which can and have led
to aspiration pneumonia she uses a
wheelchair due to poor balance and
coordination these physical disabilities
have not stopped her though because she
continues to fight
she has also been a ballet dancer since
she was three years old she aspires to
have her own ballet studio at some time
teaching others with disabilities
Mountain School used her dance in the
commercial several years ago and she was
so proud
to be a part of that it's on YouTube
still and she loves loves to show people
that
uh Caitlyn hasn't been involved in
Special Olympics through Bowling
swimming track and field and skiing
Caitlyn loves to read she reads it about
a sixth grade level of reading and
comprehension she loves nature and
history and I'm telling you we can drive
anywhere and I would get lost going back
and she Nails it she left rage you know
this is
um I'm telling you all of these
wonderful attributes because I want you
to see that Caitlyn is a real person
she's not just my daughter she's my
friend
she is taught me so many things in my
life
and she's a blessing
it's been a typical blessing but she's a
huge huge blessing
I wanted to tell you too that um
Caitlin's psychiatric disorders
unfortunately to include depression and
the frustration of not being able to
speak in the way that you and I do
Caitlyn has been in residential care
since she was about 14 years old
she lived at crotchet Mountain for seven
years and excelled in Leaps and Bounds
her father and I both live fairly close
and we were able to see her and bring
her home often
she then moved to enhanced Family Care
the first placement didn't work it
wasn't a good fit at all the second
placement went well
until her daily support staff had an
injury and was not able to work
this leftover care provider providing
24-hour care
thank you
Melissa Tuttle followed by Carol
Townsend
followed by Kimberly peace
thank you for your patience
I thought you lost my card
good afternoon I'm Carol Townsend and
this is Kim danis we are the newly
appointed chair and co-chair for the New
Hampshire Nurses Association Commission
on government affairs
um we are registered nurses and I have a
combined 60 years of nursing experience
and with nurses aides before
on page 188 section 466 of House Bill 2
the bill proposes removing the licensure
requirement for nursing assistance we
are in agreement with the Board of
Nursing that we would like this remote
so I won't expand on that it's in my
written testimony
on page 188 section 467 of House Bill 2
the bill proposes to reduce the size of
the Boards of Nursing from 11 members to
five
and reduce the overall number of nurses
from five to two which can be either RNs
or LPNs we oppose a reduction of the 11
to 5 members as this will only create
more of a barrier to the workforce and
result in delays of throughput
the Board of Nursing is responsible for
standards of practice criteria for
licensure and continuing education
disciplinary action and approval of
educational programs the nurse Practice
Act states that the LPN shall practice
under the supervision of the RN and
therefore these are not interchangeable
reducing the numbers of RNs on the board
limits the knowledge and expertise
required to establish standards for
practice
and my last point on page 78 section 226
of House Bill 2 the bill proposes a
delay of the effective date of the
implementation of a workplace violence
program two years out to July of 2020
. the findings from the New Hampshire
Healthcare violence prevention
Consortium reported that violence was
experienced across all responding age
groups and during multiple stages of
patient care
occurring multiple times
per week for many staff and enacted by a
variety of individuals including
patients family members and co-workers
perhaps the most important finding is
that 54 of health care workers did not
feel safe in their place of work in
addition to potential and our actual
harm to healthcare staff it is important
to note that violence in health care
settings put patient and health health
and safety at risk as well thank you for
and was the second person Kimberly or
thank you Mr Cherry thank you members of
the committee for your patience and your
hard work and time today I am the chair
of the legislative committee for the New
Hampshire Association of natural
resource scientists we have provided
written comment I just wanted to follow
up on a few key points in our comments
it's particularly to read but statements
that were provided today we are the
association that is a Statewide
non-profit Professional Organization
whose membership includes Wetland
scientists soil scientists and Wildlife
biologists from the professional
community and the state's academic and
public sectors and we are your
environmental resource protectors and
the state and we're very proud of that
fact our legislative committee has
reviewed House Bill 2 and we strongly
oppose section 453 of House Bill 2 which
would repeal the functions of the board
of natural scientists and the
certifications including the certified
Mountain scientists and the certified
soil scientists two important points
that were brought up today there is no
National license or certification for a
professional Wetland science or
professional soil scientist there has
been proposing that there are similar
type of certifications and licensors but
as we detailed in our comments that were
provided to the committee there are no
in fact no comparisons to what we do
here in the state of New Hampshire we
have a certification process that uses a
test field testing a combination of
education and experience and we believe
that that is essential and necessary to
continue the protection of these
resources in our state there are over
180 professional Wetlands certified
Wetland scientists that are working in
the state and the certified Wetland
scientists and the certified soil
scientists are important roles in Des
and we provide the the support to those
permitting processes that as Mr Burt has
pointed out from the board if we do not
have that process in place we would have
to refer to Des staff to do that which
are already overworked and and we have a
very long permitting backlog that we're
currently all working against it at this
point so it's important that we keep
these Protections in place as well as in
support of our municipalities who rely
on this the conservation commissions to
rely on the Wetland scientists and we
are supporting the reward reorganization
and merging with other relevant boards
if it would streamline the certification
process and make it easier to maintain
provided that the standards for
certified button scientists and
certified soil scientists are not
lowered and that we do provide adequate
representation on that board I think
those are the main points and I just
wanted to bring those up to your
attention those are the items that we
are countering and again we strongly
oppose House Bill 2 Section 453 and
we're happy to hear that we're when the
CWS and CSS have been pulled out of this
legislation to be
free so thank you very much for your
time
thank you
and lastly I told Dr Warner she could
thank you so very much for allowing me
to speak again
I'm Dr Deborah Warner and I'm taking off
my board hat
I wore it all that time so I could just
take it off
um I'm speaking as an individual I'm a
psychologist in Littleton New Hampshire
I've worked in many settings I've also
been on the board of mental health
practice when it was involved the
psychologists before and I'm as you know
I serve in a similar capacity today on
our board which I'm not speaking for I'm
telling you some things that I
they pertain to my experiences
um
this legislation proposes an experiment
that she prescribes an experiment that's
already happened and failed the board of
mental health practice had the
psychologist for 15 years after we had
already been an independent board for 50
years before that
we have been successful board and they
merged them together it did not go well
in 15 years the board of mental health
with in inadequate professional depth it
was
struggled to regulate the professions
and it made many mistakes there were a
number of Supreme Court appeals that
succeeded in overturning the board
decisions quite a few times it was then
judged by the national insurers and had
a reputation nationally that New
Hampshire was the worst state in which
to practice psychology
our insurers
put in testimony 10 years ago when we
faced this Exodus originally which
hopefully we don't have to do again
um
and they put in testimony to that that
it was the most dangerous state
if professionals avoided moving to our
state you couldn't get psychologists to
come we have a shortage of health
professionals we don't need to drive
them away our state was upgraded in the
insurance rates we paid higher Insurance
than the other states
I just want to tell you there's no
animosity between these professions
we've worked together on cases it's fine
we get along fine we just are in it's
inappropriate to be regulating each
other we bring different things to the
table
I wanted to let you know this is not as
cost-saving measure at all the fees for
licenses cover
125 of the cost of operating our license
it's not State money you you profit you
get more there's a there's a bonus for
this day
there would be only four members that
are professionals on this five-member
board
one is a psychologist who could be
either a regular psychologist or a
school psychologist there's a drug and
alcohol counselor a master's level
health counselor and a social worker and
only one public member on our board now
and before there were three public
members we value the public members they
provide a good balance and help the
issues and the impact on the community
be weighed out in a balanced fashion
I want to say also that the one
psychology member who would be either a
regular psychologist of which there's
more than 20 specialties
or a school psychologist who's not
allowed to practice outside of a school
that they don't they could not cover the
diversity of care
if that school psychologist is a cags
certificate of advanced graduate study
which is a one-year certificate
they are going to be badly compromised
and in underqualified
to evaluate the rest of the profession
this is a bad idea I wanted to make sure
this got on record because I hope we
don't have to face this again in 10
years and I hope we take care of it now
thank you very much thank you Dr Warner
members of the committee
thank you all for your patience I hope
you've all taken notes and observed all
these inputs from the public
we will discuss them again as we go
and by the way members take the day off
tomorrow
all right public hearing for hb1 and hb2